oh boy Anheuser-Busch at an emergency
meeting with Distributors promising them
don't worry any other marketing we do
it's going to get checked yeah
everybody's pissed off in one
supermarket chain they're saying they
saw Bud Light sales go down 50 percent
and I kind of feel like
in places where it matters when they
when they actively choose their orders
meaning smaller businesses and Regional
stores I bet they're seeing a much
bigger impact from the boycott as
opposed to like a big venue chain or an
arena I just said put in an order for
like you know 5 000 cases or whatever
without thinking about it sales dropping
in my opinion implies individuals at the
smaller business level bars and stores
are choosing to avoid it big
corporations aren't paying attention
that makes sense now that it's having a
huge impact on the regional stores
this emergency meeting means a whole lot
ladies and gentlemen we can win this
culture War so we'll talk about that
plus we got some other crazy stories in
Tennessee where thanks to the work of
Matt Walsh and the daily wire they
actually got child sex change surgeries
banned the doj is now intervening and
seeking to make sure as they say under
the 14th Amendment it cannot be banned
and interestingly in Florida
after uh they passed a bill that would
ban children attending lewd adult
performances a local pride parade in
Florida was shut down and now you've got
a bunch of Democrats being like oh no oh
look they were forced to shut down their
pride event it's kind of like the
context around that is they chose to
shut it down because they're no longer
allowed to show adult lewd Behavior to
children and that's that's what's
happening so uh yeah we're going to talk
all about that before we get started we
got an amazing sponsor tonight it is
cast Brew Coffee head over to
castbrew.com and get your order today
caspro has begun shipping that means for
those of you that got in your orders
early on you will start seeing your
signature rise with Roberto Jr breakfast
blend and Appalachian Knights Colombian
or French rust arriving at your doors
soon
and uh I believe that that's it so it
has begun it has begun shipping uh first
come first serve so those who ordered
first you'll start seeing this come in
we're gonna be rolling out I think three
new Blends in the next month and a half
or so so for the time being pick up cast
brew coffee this is our coffee company
that we'll be selling at our coffee shop
and available online and it directly
supports the show so we don't have to
worry about sponsors or undo pressure
from outside forces so these weirdo
activists who want to go to these
comedies and say why are you sponsoring
the show okay please send an email to
Casper letting them know you're mad that
uh they're helping fund our show and in
the meantime buy some Casper coffee
drink it it's delicious and you'll be
helping support our work also head over
to timcast.com click that join us button
to become a member join our Discord
server with like-minded individuals and
if you sign up at the 25 per month level
or if you're a member for six months
you'll get access to you'll be you you
will be able to call into our uncensored
members only show which you also get
access to Monday through Thursday at 10
10 p.m on the front page of Tim
timcast.com so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Lucas of T-Rex arms
thanks for having me yeah who are you
what do you do so 10 years ago I started
a defense manufacturing company that
over the years has grown to be an
eight-figure company we've got 80
employees and over that time I also
became a YouTuber and I hate to say it a
social media influencer and
unfortunately and I also shoot guns and
unhealthy amount literally unhealthy an
unhealthy amount like the lead is
getting all over you and is that lead my
hips are jacked up I can't dead lift
without one foot being in front of the
other oh wow wrist problems so yeah a
lot of you switch arms and start working
on the left unfortunately not really so
it's just something I'll deal with for
the rest of my life and that's okay
that's fine well all right well thanks
for hanging out man we got Phil Labonte
hanging out hello everyone philibonti
lead singer of All That Remains
anti-communist encounter revolutionary
like nian's not here he joined a
different show he's uh he's now uh yeah
on Alex Stein's show yeah and a Defector
and not loyal at all so I'm here I'm
Hannah Claire Brillo I'm a writer for
timcast.com I'm so glad to be sitting
here unlike some people who are in Texas
just kidding
and I am here right now
um surge.com what's up all right let's
jump into this first story from the
Daily Mail ladies and gentlemen
Anheuser-Busch Executives hold closed
door meeting with beer distributors and
told them any marketing will be heavily
screened before it goes public bosses
held the closed our meeting in DC this
week where they laid out plans going
forward they say that bench benj
Steinman editor of beer marketers
Insight said the spending on the brand
fell off a cliff last year but Anheuser
Bush execs are promising to rectify the
situation Bud Light sales have fallen
dramatically since the Dylan Mulvaney
boycott which I think most of you know
now they're reporting this Bud light's
pores plummet before partnering with
Mulvaney in April 1st it dropped by six
percent to the 15th but in one
supermarket chain Bud Light sales
plunged 50 percent at Stu Leonard so the
Tri-State air this is Westchester County
Long Island Connecticut New Jersey the
reason why this story is so significant
ladies and gentlemen is because this is
a Democrat Urban liberal stronghold
seeing one of the biggest declines so
when we hear Kid Rock is you know taking
a gun and firing upon a bunch of Bud
Lights we're like oh well yeah he's Kid
Rock you know he's out in the country or
whatever he wants to be a cowboy baby or
something and you know I don't know is
that what the song was yeah okay well
there you go with the top lead back and
the Sunshine you get it you get it so
but but we expect conservatives to do
that when we get news that they're
having an emergency meeting in D.C and
in a major liberal area Connecticut New
Jersey Long Island that beer sales are
dropping 50 at a major regional
Supermarket uh boycott's working yeah
congratulations everybody Stu honors was
known as the Disneyland of uh I love
students it's the best thing of all time
highly recommend going the one that was
near me uh had all of the like fruits
that sing and stuff like that like if if
you can't keep people in your store if
you can't get them to buy Bud Light
under those circumstances like you're
just not going to there's there's no
better grocery store being from New
England you know originally and and you
know living New Hampshire the fact that
I haven't heard of this this uh change
it's not what it's not as far like
Connecticut is the only part of New
England that has it like it doesn't get
to Massachusetts you're too far gone
okay uh but it is it is delightful and
I'm glad that their customers are
apparently taking part in this boycott I
never would have guessed check this out
they say uh
on top of the marketing Blitz Executives
working for Bud Light will go through a
more rigorous screening process
according to one northeast-based beer
distributor
quote there will be an improved
screening process before any marketing
hits the public Executives will have to
go through a more rigorous screening
process according to beer Business Daily
wholesalers received a letter in which
Executives explained the entire
situation including quote this was one
single can given to one social media
influencer this can was not made for
production or sale to the general public
they are trying to trick people the
issue wasn't that one can was made the
issue was Dylan Mulvaney promoting the
beer in general yeah we have an
influencer among in our midst you know
influencers make money off of the post
right it's not that we have to have his
face on every single beer can it's the
fact that he is getting paid to promote
it that you guys thought this was worth
the money
a lot of money and worth access to its
audience I think that's the biggest
thing you know they're trying so hard to
act like nothing's happening but there
was that uh that video I don't know if
we should we talked about it last night
but this guy in Las Vegas he's a Las
Vegas vlogger that's what he does he's
walking into stores and being like I
wonder if this is a thing and then he's
like oh wow no one's buying Bud Light
yeah I I was I was questioning whether
or not this would have impact and when
it initially started
um I was a little apprehensive about the
idea I thought that it would look like
people were attacking Dylan and it has
turned into what looks like the most
effective uh boycott the rightest scene
in a long long time I can't remember the
last time that there's been a boycott of
uh something from the right that has
been this effective well and it's
obvious that people are upset with the
brand yeah and they're really focusing
on the brand not the person which is
good because then it doesn't seem like
you're bullying right and it was kind of
they were talking about Dylan the first
two days which is reasonable because you
know sure bringing him in and all that
but it turned into the brand which I
think is that's the correct approach
because they're the ones that made the
decision they're the ones that make the
product they're the people that people
want to buy the product from is it every
now the the actual cans or bottles in
the stores it was like a limited run
that actually had Dylan's face on them
no they only from what I remember in
Phil can correct me here they only made
this one can to celebrate 365 days of
girl to Mark the one year point of
Dylan's hole where those in stores you
have to order no you couldn't you
couldn't believe they just made a custom
thing
gotcha but that wasn't the issue right
because the video I saw first was Dylan
with a bunch of beers saying I don't
even know what March Madness is let's
all drink beer and then cracking open
beer had nothing to do with any kind of
promotional can or anything like that
and then all of a sudden everyone was
like screw Bud Light and it's tagged
with the like hashtag Bud Light spot a
partner or something like that like it's
denoted as a form of advertising I think
what the strangest part of it like like
you're right I'm actually glad that
there's not a specific targeting filming
because Domo vanity is doing exactly
what Dylan Mulvaney has always done and
you can have separate criticism of that
but Anheuser-Busch chose to partner with
him and if yeah you put position people
in positions of power in your company
who thought this was a good idea I'm
glad that you're starting to rethink
this I would like them to admit that
they're just saying like our rigorous
screening processes we will hire some
conservatives after years and years of
hiring liberals probably what they're
talking about is okay we can't say we
goofed up and they're all fired because
then the trans Community will say we're
horrible and bigoted and all of that and
so I mean not even though here's how I
imagine the meeting goes down they tell
everybody look we understand you're
concerned we're gonna have a meeting in
DC come meet and they all walk in and
there's a guy in his suit and he goes
listen our customers are dumb as dumb
guests they are so stupid so here's what
we're gonna do We're Not Gonna apologize
We're not gonna say anything we're gonna
completely ignore all of them and let it
all blow over that's that's what they're
saying right now I mean I I don't know
if it's quite that extreme but they are
definitely trying to be like they're
definitely trying to run away from it as
opposed to addressing it and saying
they're sorry and I do think that that
apologizing uh is appropriate because
they it's they're they're they're seeing
a a distinct reaction from their their
user base from their their customer base
that's what brands are built on many
many of you may be wondering why why is
this so important why have we talked
about this for three weeks now why are
we leading the show with it right now
because I want to make sure that every
major corporation knows that when you
engage in sponsorships and advertisings
advertising like this it will be so
toxic to your company you will be
reeling from it there has been no resp
it's been it's been entirely uh no
negative response from all of the
essentially since you know the the since
June became you know pride month and has
been celebrated so openly in the west
and and for probably the past 10 years
or so there's not been any kind of
considerable pushback and to see
something you know pushing back to say
hey maybe we should moderate this a
little bit because at this point the
trans question like that that is not
that is not built on on solid arguments
there's there's a lot of questions there
are people that there's there's evidence
that that it's not a good idea to yeah
exactly like they like multiple
countries in Europe have said no it's
not working yeah and then you there's
even been several studies showing that
could it could increase suicidal
ideation so let's make sure we're
helping people 100 but but more more to
the point my biggest concern is
they effectively sponsored Elsa gate
right the easiest way for me to explain
what went down with the Dom of any
sponsorship is a person exploited an
algorithm for to produce strange and
off-putting content that was offensive
to a lot of women a lot of uh and I'll
end men and then Budweiser did no
research said whatever look this
person's got followers it must be
popular but I do think it's a fantastic
wake-up call as to what AI is doing to
humans humans and what AI promotes or I
shouldn't say AI but algorithms sure it
is incongruous just because someone has
views does not mean they are popular and
this proves it and I hope that if we
keep the pressure on
than other corporations will start to
realize like hey look just because that
person's on TV doesn't mean they're
popular you're gonna get the algorithms
to really internalize retweets or not
endorsements that's where we get that
idea to go to really I used to see sorry
I was gonna say I've heard some
YouTubers say like yeah I don't care if
you dislike my video any interaction
actually helps I don't know if that's
still the case I'm not that experienced
with YouTube but it is yeah so so really
like anyone commenting on Dylan's
posting this is terrible is actually
just still helping yeah you do you get
into the comments on on T-Rex arm stuff
still currently all right as as much as
I can and primarily to learn more about
our customers not any other reason
um we talked to some marketing folks
last week who said yeah even if your
company responds to every comment on you
know Instagram YouTube Facebook uh that
greatly affects the algorithm even if
you stop by and go thumbs up you're
adding to the comment count and that
makes a difference so when do you get
the trans Shooters well
um yeah wait a minute
I I I posted a photo a year ago and it
was uh it was a gun on a trans flag and
I said something like trans rights are
human rights trans gun rights are human
rights and I got a false DM my I believe
it was a false dmca takedown activists
started this is the weirdest thing
leftist screen grabbed my post and then
started insulting me over it and I'm
like it's it's so weird that I said
something they should agree with and
instead they attacked me and then filed
the dmca takedown to get the video that
the photo deleted from my Twitter
account and then I'm just like I don't
know what these people think because I'm
like two-way all the way I had a guy who
tweeted me saying you you think only
white people should have guns I'm like
what are you talking about I think the
Black Panther should be marching around
with guns all day every day and they're
like oh okay bass yeah
where these people live in a wacky
alternate dimension of what we here
believe it it is interesting though I
did notice and I I could be wrong an
uptick in the obviously when the
shooting occurred a couple weeks ago
there were lots of gun companies and I
also tweeted some things about
um you know calling into question you
know should gun companies and this is a
big discussion happening right now do we
have to serve and service everyone who
wants to own a gun or can we go hey this
is what we believe is a company we're
interested in selling to these types of
people
um we put our core values out there and
usually it some people aren't going to
agree with those so they're not going to
come and buy from us and it did look
like after the the shooting in in um in
Tennessee occurred uh the trans
Community was definitely much more
interested in talking about guns and gun
rights for themselves and getting
involved in that whole things I had all
kinds of people to stopping my Twitter
giving their opinion and I feel like a
year ago probably when you posted that
flag that was not as much of a
discussion and they were probably more
anti-gun no they're like oh no now we
need to be pro-gun they were pro-gun
yeah there was there was a it was a
picture of a trans flag with a gun on it
and then there was people were posting
pictures of trans people wearing patches
and armbands of the trans flag with guns
and I'm like I'm all for it I like there
there's there's an interesting
discussion that's emerged uh following
what happened in Nashville where they're
saying you know a bunch of conservatives
are like maybe we shouldn't allow trans
people to have guns or something like
that and I'm just like not interested in
that not not interested in that
conversation if someone poses a clear
and present danger or like I mean like
they're literally on on the path
choosing a weapon right you can stop
them but short of I guess due process
maybe they committed a felony and a
court has determined through through
somehow yeah a legal Pro like due
process yeah your rights cannot be
infringed upon well you bring up a good
point everyone wants to talk about the
gun thing well the government has guns I
mean criminals have guns everyone
already has guns the guns shouldn't even
be the guys I said the same thing twice
what was that oh yeah the criminals in
the government yeah exactly but they all
have guns so like that shouldn't be the
discussion if trans people have guns
fine if if you know the LGBT community
wants to have guns that's fine they
should everyone's everyone can have guns
let's talk about other things instead
but got gun owners and I was going to
say that are some of the biggest wusses
out there like they really are in 2020
we saw this because For the Longest Time
gun owners were like we have guns for
the government and then 2020 happened we
had the antifa stuff and made the
peaceful Times Obviously and then they
went oh there's other people with guns
who aren't our friends we need to do
something about that or have the
government step in it's like no no no no
no don't don't ask for the government to
step in you're having them do what we
don't want them to do to us what you do
is you train exactly that's what you do
just be better than everyone because
most people aren't going out there and
training I mean I'm I I'm a guy that's
very Pro get out there and train go out
there and like learn how to shoot your
guns I mean Lucas knows how to shoot
guns when did you guys get interested in
guns like is this something you grew up
with is there something that happened I
played Call of Duty and that was enough
for me I had some video games gun
pipeline video games are the Gateway the
Gateway they they they create more gun
owners in the NRA ever hopes to yeah
he's like oh they're they're gone yeah
they're gone I'm not a big fan but yeah
video games absolutely the Call of Duty
franchise which I'm very thankful I got
to work on the good one that came years
ago guys guys the NRA is very important
it's a very important organization we
need to make sure that the NRA you gotta
donate a lot of money we need to make
sure that the NRA is out there so that
way they've got something to attack
didn't the NRA support the NFA oh
they've supported so the NRA has done
some good things like the sunset clause
for the weapons assault ban all that but
for the most part they are extremely
funny the worst thing about the NRA that
people won't talk about are is their
training programs which are like they
have a they have a like a rule you are
not allowed to call a gun a weapon is
that right that's too dangerous and real
quick describe explain fuddy to people
who don't know so funny are like people
who go uh 1911 is better than any pistol
out there won two world wars
is better than an air 15. it's still
very esoteric esoteric so I don't want
that plastic stuff on my rifle it's a
reference to Elmer Fudd yeah it's old
old times more or less he's not getting
with the times these people who are like
look I'm I'm a gun owner and I think we
should have gun control
generally that we don't need 30 rounds
for hunting so let's ban 30 round high
capacity magazines to go to 10 do you
see deer running around Kevlar what do
you need that for exactly that's exactly
it but yeah the NRA the the worst thing
is not their political stuff it's the
firearms training it's the culture that
they're perpetuating to even hunter's
education don't store ammunition with a
gun the gun's pretty useless without the
ammunition like you actually want to
keep them together because weapons are
for people not just for Bambi but these
these and they train them young that way
these people have never loaded a weapon
no and so I I can tell you this right
um I got a 30 30 uh Winchester repeater
it's amazing and it's it's real
difficult to load the 33rd yes I get
stuck the the the plunger gets stuck and
all that stuff and then when it comes to
loading even like you know a Glock with
nine millimeter they have speed loaders
for a reason if you're trained in your
practice you can load it fairly quickly
but I just think anybody who has a gun
understands that if someone if you hear
you're a glass shatter and and then
someone yelled all right boys let's go
you're gonna be like uh-oh and then
you're gonna open the box and you're
gonna be like just let me give me a
second let me push these in and load
this no it has to like when when you're
when you are being prepared for
self-defense you you need to have your
weapon prepared and safely secured in a
way yeah you know that you can access it
and that uh it's responsible but what's
the point someone told me this
when um I was asking like around the
first time I was getting a weapon what's
proper like storage and safety protocol
and I'm going to keep it relatively
vague for the show but they just
basically said what's the point of
having a weapon if you can't readily
exit to defend yourself from an intruder
so just consider that yep and then have
a serious conversation with yourself
what is a gun for yeah they are for Homo
sapiens they were designed ever since
gunpowder was you know developed and
then it was used for fire fireworks to
disrupt Cavalry Charges after that it
was always weaponized for human beings
it wasn't just made for hunting like
that is what they're for and the problem
is gun owners well it's a weapon every
time I say that they go they go oh Lucas
you can't say that because then the
left's gonna use that to ban stuff I'm
like no the reason we're in all this
mess and gun regulations are happening
is we've always been on the defense and
culturally we're losing because of it we
won't just say the facts and what's
going on I I think it's fair to be more
general what weapons are for destructive
ends yep and that doesn't mean it's
always bad destructive things can be
good things right if if you're defending
someone a machete for instance you're
using it to go in clear brush to to
carve a path through the woods to help
people more freely move about but it's
also can be the weapon yeah and uh
famously Alfred Nobel made dynamite TNT
I think I don't know the same thing but
TNT I guess because he wanted to help
people mine and then they called him The
Merchant of death and he was and they
you know the story like they
accidentally published his obituary and
then he was like is that what they think
of me he's like holy crap oh that must
be brutal that he read his obituary
before he passed yeah and then you and
then he made the piece the Nobel prizes
he was like I better be known for
something much better than that I didn't
know that yeah but it was weaponized
obituaries and Records let's let's go
back to that first the first question
with all of us we're talking about uh
mental illness uh weapon ownership and
stuff like that and for the longest time
we were talking about red flag laws and
everybody on the right and all the
two-way people were like absolutely not
you cannot red flag people and then the
Nashville shooting happened and all of a
sudden conservatives were like we should
not let these people have guns and I'm
just sitting here like yo wrong yeah
well so the mental the mental um
that that whole thing's interesting
because the issue that I have with that
whole conversation is by what standard
and who gets to Define if someone is
mentally unwell because if I go to the
right you know uh you know doctor
clinician or whatever and I say I really
like guns for these reasons this is what
I actually think about the government
this is what I think about balkanization
of our country next one in XYZ they
could say you're a little unwell for
thinking these things you want to
homeschool your kids you're married
you're not running around doing all this
other stuff you're on well you can't own
guns right that's I'm not saying that
would happen today but in 10 years I
mean who gets to standardize who is
mentally well and so that's a pretty
slippery slope this is why when a couple
years ago we were talking about uh
felons and firearms and I said as soon
as you get out of jail you get your
right to keeping bear arms yep I agree
and what people responded with was
several people conservatives were like
no because you went through a a process
you you got your due process and through
due process your rights were deprived
that is constitutional meaning you have
a right to life liberty in the pursuit
of happiness but if you break the law we
can deprive you of those rights through
due process meaning you go to a judge
there was a hearing you were found
guilty the same thing is true of your
guns and my response that is then just
like so what is a life sentence then
yeah it's either you die or I guess
you're in jail your whole life yeah
that's yeah you don't get yourself ever
and so my my issue still is now due
process isn't necessarily an app a
perfect standard right because we are we
are at the point of polarization in this
country where like you said you will say
something like I think everybody should
have guns I'm like well you're clearly
insane I think machine guns should be
legal okay I also wonder how the mental
health screenings work because we have
the shooter in Louisville whose parents
are like no he was having some sort of
Crisis we were aware of it like but he
was able to get a gun theoretically like
wouldn't this have triggered so I feel
like some people can I just don't
understand the Practical applications of
some of these yeah and the problem is p
the government and people want to play
Minority Report they want to stop the
crime before it happens you can't do
that it doesn't actually work oh but
it's coming yeah the AI chat gp7
whatever is gonna probably do it but
it's not practical and it's not going to
work and it's only going to cause and
we've seen this up north where red flag
loss have gotten innocent people killed
where they show up to the doorstep the
guy comes out there's an altercation
he's like why are you guys here I
haven't done Community crimes yet ends
up getting shot there's been at least
two of those uh that have happened it's
going to do more harm than good and
besides that according to all these
shootings have happened at least in the
last like five years uh supposedly the
FBI already knew about the person yeah
they constantly already watching them so
it's like well it obviously doesn't work
already I mean you guys have been trying
to do this kind of the FBI tries to
prevent crimes right they're just aware
stuff is going on but they're like maybe
we'll help you assist do that crime yeah
it's yeah it's a slippery slope and and
it's not something that I think I think
conservatives and people in generally to
get away from and just go when a crime
happens we have people there who can
shoot back and that's how we resolve it
because we call the cops to resolve it
while attack after while it's happening
so why not address it sooner when the
incident actually occurs and if we saw
that happen more often a lot of these
shootings would go down if people
realize like hey if we posted photos of
the corpse of the shooter afterwards
kind of what happened in Tennessee a lot
less of the shooter culture would be
happening I mean I don't know I guess my
concern is there are a lot of people
with no purpose anymore and no community
and no path towards notability right and
and maybe notability is the wrong word
but but people want recording value
feeling value and so they decide one way
they'll make people remember their names
is being evil yeah because uh if they
can't be a famous superhero they'll just
be the villain it's the easiest path but
we got we have this we do have the story
here's a story from uh the
post-millennial
breaking Nashville trans Shooters
Manifesto to be released by authorities
Metro Nashville Police Department Public
Information office told Fox 17 on
Thursday the investigation has advanced
the point that writings from the
Covenant shooter are now being reviewed
for public release that process is
underway and will take a little time so
I I think we're going to get it soon and
what we already know is that it does
relate to politics and what we've heard
from various news sources and even we've
had some people reach out saying that
they were either in the know or
something so it's all unconfirmed there
have been other show saying they have
inside sources that suggest this
individual was anti-trump was was angry
over the the conservative politics and
the Banning on on transgender surgery
child sex change surgery and things like
that and they were trying to you know
maximize that Carnage so I think it'll
be interesting to see and I'm curious
how it manifests in the public because
when this happened within days the
Democrats turned it into a fundraiser
for themselves it is I I look at the
aftermath of the way that the Democratic
party and and the politicians
surrounding the the the situation have
behaved it is atrocious and I thought
that I was not I thought that I had
gotten to a point where I where I
couldn't be shocked anymore but I'm
really surprised at how the narrative
has really really been like oh it's
about trans people it's like a trans
person actually killed and targeted
Christians children yeah and you have
managed to make the trans people the
victims that is absolutely astounding
well above all else you cannot be
bigoted and you should know better uh I
don't I don't I think the important
distinction with this individual because
I wanna I'll bring it back to gun rights
is people saw this shooter was trans
therefore they were talking about
banning guns for Trans people and I'm
like no no this was a leftist gender
ideologue yeah that's a big difference I
think it's important that we we have a
distinction between someone who happens
to be transgender and someone who is in
a cult sure of a varying ideology yeah
because there are people who are trans
who are nowhere near that ideology and
we're friends and it's just like I don't
want that I don't want my friends rights
curtailed because this person's a
leftist wacko the leftism is the problem
or I bet my favorite way to put it is
when Tucker Carlson was accused of being
racist he was like what white liberal
women are the problem that's who I'm
complaining about because I have a
problem with black people so I'm like
exactly it's the ideology right it's
it's the cult yeah yeah outside both
worldview right that's what it comes
down to and so even then even with the
world view people have a right to keep
in bear arms leftists have a right to
keep in bear arms and I'm I'm not gonna
but I will say we're getting to the
point where it's not going to matter
whether you want them to or not if it's
active conflict if you have people who
are of leftist ideology like that dude
at the ice facility and I think it was
in Tacoma who fire bound to start
shooting at it or the guy who killed
Aaron Daniels at a certain point it's
like okay
we need to stop violent political
extremists yeah and then and what do you
do so it's it's uh it reminds me of that
Carl popper I mean the left likes to
share
if you tolerate intolerance and
tolerance wins and that's how they
justify Banning people's speech and I'm
like I believe in the right keeping bear
arms for everybody I believe in free
speech Free Press religion all that
stuff but then when War happens
all of this stuff is meaningless you
know yeah well then things are different
because then it's you've got supply
lines who's selling guns to who and so
the whichever sides over here will have
their own infrastructure or lack thereof
depending on their funding mechanism and
then the people over here will have
their thing and then it's very clear
right now it's there's not really battle
lines there kind of are and there's gun
stores these people walk in and they're
like do I sell this person or not and
they have the freedom to deny sales uh
the ATF actually likes it when gun
stores don't sell to people that might
be a threat but who are those people
this is actually a good idea for like a
video we could do have someone dress up
as antifa like wearing antifa clothes
and go into a gunshot they say yeah and
you'd be like hey I want to I want to
buy guns I'll do it I wanna but they
might be like okay Phil
I love All That Remains actually you
know the uh the green monster gun shop
in in Martinsburg I've been recognized
twice exactly you're like walking oh
yeah I'm anti-fun like no you're not
built you're watching the show get out
of here get out of here
but I I think you know I think the
appropriate response is if someone
wearing antifa Gear walk into a gun shop
they should be like let me know what you
need
I I I don't think that that is the
philosophical challenge right now should
a business be like no you are our
enemies you are dangerous and I will not
sell you this weapon because that's
actually a fair point uh correct if I'm
wrong but if if someone had a gun store
has suspicions that a person may use a
weapon for criminal ends they can deny
sale but but isn't it a requirement did
an eye sale
um probably prop it technically probably
is it probably is like hey don't sell
them that gun you don't want to be the
guy the cop comes to you and says did
you did you think this guy was gonna say
something and then be like yeah I
totally thought he was gonna go shoot up
them all and I sold it anyway yeah he
said something I did it I wanted the
money no I'm pretty sure they get in
trouble if they're like the guy came in
and he was talking about committing a
crime and I said well here's your weapon
like no you're sweating everywhere yeah
respectively an accessory to the crime
so then if someone comes in wearing
antifa gear you could I might be like oh
man I know dude Well yeah if it's like
let's see let's go back to the peaceful
times in 2020 and someone walks in right
then when all that stuff's going going
on in let's say Oregon oh hands down uh
I think there would be a good case to be
like you know what I I'd rather not sell
to you no I go to someone else slam dunk
case you're not the kind of person I
want to assist I'll stop there I say if
if I owned a gun store and it was during
the summer of love and someone with
antifa BLM gear came on I'd be like get
out right now one of my closest friends
questions one of my closest friends in
New Hampshire the gun shop that that
Highlander arms of buddy of mine owns
like if someone went in there and he
knew that they were a leftist there is
no way yeah he would they he was gun
Source he'd kick him out himself like
most gun stores you think would do that
not all I'll take that back uh the ones
with backbones so maybe a little bit
less than half but like dick Sporting
Goods wouldn't right
right okay here you go have a good time
yeah but I feel like if an if a guy with
like an antifa bandana and like a shirt
and everything walked in there and it
was like it's time to go fight for
justice wear the gun like break this way
sir and they'd walk him over and be like
here we have a 12 gauge and it also yeah
and it also well it also depends is it a
chain you know a place where you don't
have control or is it a little
mom-and-pop gun shop where the owner is
literally there at the desk because
there's a huge difference between the
service you're going to get from both
places like the little gun store in my
County no that guy would totally deny
sail but if it were took Sporting Goods
no that employee's just going to be like
I can't do anything I don't think it's a
corporation I can't I can't do it I
don't think he would he would even say
that he'd be like right this way sir yep
yep here we have a fine selection of
firearms for you exactly they would have
no idea gun sales at Dick's Sporting
Goods he'd be like buy an extra well and
and Dick Sporting Goods got boycotted
they don't even sell guns anymore I
don't think yeah
okay
and uh and like uh and I think they sell
like 10 22s and stuff like that yeah fud
guns yeah
those are great if you go to the uh the
dicks out here in I think it's a dicks
in Maryland they have basically just
shotguns and I think they might have
some 22s and it's just it's just it's
it's pandering they they pulled up the
ARs like what was it six years ago four
years ago
um after a shooting and they were like
we're not gonna sell those weapons of
war we'll just sell shotguns and then
Walmart same thing Walmart pulled out
like Anyway six years ago and then they
finally removed all guns so let me let
me let me ask you a question if um if we
were talking about maximizing defense
minimizing collateral damage being safe
and secure which would you prefer you're
in your house you have I don't know
let's just say like what is it like a 72
caliber Sabo slug for deer
um and your 12 gauge or you have like an
AR-15 AR hands down short barrel
suppressed and and and that's so illegal
right like suppressors it's like
restricted my point is just
Joe Biden says to fire the shotgun into
the air scare away yeah and they and
they and they're trying to sell people
like Buckshot for home defense for bird
shot or or bird shot but either way like
I kind of feel like
it would be fairly brutal to use a 12
gauge on somebody in your home and put
like a 10 inch hole in their chest oh
it'd be very violent this is correct
this is the problem with shotguns and
again this is like fud Knowledge from
the past shotguns are so much harder to
use well by an untrained person than
handing them an error 15. I mean the
AK-47 originally though was designed for
the average conscripts to use very
simple to manipulate and function a
shotgun on the other hand if it's a pump
you got to pump it every time you pull
the trigger which already mentally if
you haven't trained that most people
aren't going to Rack a second round
that's just how it's going to be an AR
it's 30 round mag goes in pull the
charging handle safety then I can pull
the trigger 30 times and I'm good to go
super simple to use and The Recoil and
The Recoil when we go out to the range
with people man they do not they think
the shotguns are the easy ones yeah and
and I'm like we have the shoulder pads
for the shotgun if you want to use them
like why like now it's like you might
want to try using the like the ar-556 or
whatever because that's oh yeah you're
not gonna you might be like oh wow that
was it but that's the point I guess the
argument being made by the gun control
people is
too easy to use yep smartphones are hard
they well and they don't even know
exactly what are the only argument they
really use is just in arguments because
it's inconsistent it's it's a weapon of
War it's what the military has and I'm
doing a video on it next week is an M4A1
the military has the same as a civilian
AR-15 well it actually turns out
civilian era 15s are better m4a1s the
military has a lot of them are shot out
they're crap AR-15s I can buy right now
for a thousand dollars or better than
what the military has yeah and the left
is not like that we uh I've got a KSG 25
oh you're familiar yeah yeah so for
those that aren't it's uh it can hold 25
shotgun shells and uh we're at the range
and it's loaded with Buckshot and the
wave of Devastation is is is Bonkers oh
yeah here's the crazy thing that's legal
in Maryland but an M1A is illegal that
is so funny an M1A is a is an assault
weapon yep and I'm like that's kind of
weird because for those if those don't
understand if you've got 25 shells
you've got 25 uh Charles buck shot I'm
watching this thing just melt a melt the
the target the wood flying everywhere
it's being ripped apart like a chainsaw
is gutting it from every direction
it's kind of it it was kind of cool but
it was like also I think it's 225 lead
balls if you're shooting like nine shot
or something well placed
like well-placed shotgun shells will
remove parts of bodies like you will
literally take an arm off yeah if you're
if you're skilled with a shotgun it will
remove body parts large chunks very
Politically Incorrect very important but
this is a great that's a crazy thing to
me that that's the argument they always
go to is get a shotgun and I'm like
there's there's exotic rounds there's
weird stuff there's dragon's breath yeah
can you imagine a CCTV like video and
you just dragon's breath first it's
magnesium right I think yeah it's just
dragon's breath is like a shell loaded
with magnesium so it sprays flaming
metal at you I just awesome and that's
the stuff that they're like that's fine
yeah that's that's that that's the stuff
we're not trying to keep but it's
because they don't understand it better
exactly so sbrs the perfect this is
another perfect thing so SBR short
barrel rifles are technically illegal
unless you pay this little tax stamp to
the government
it's exactly a bribe I can own machine
guns because I paid 2 500 to the ATF and
other people can't it's the most
Preposterous thing ever but an SBR you
know a barrel below 16 inches is
technically illegal unless you do
paperwork to attack stamp pay 200 but
his last lethal than a 20-inch M16 which
will penetrate body armor with the right
ammo and a little 10.3556 can't so it's
it's they don't they don't know what
they're doing obviously with the
regulation they're old they're outdated
but a 20 inch M16 is way more lethal so
let me know there's a person what's
going on with this um this uh pistol
brace band they just did I saw there was
a video of members of Congress
questioning the ATF and the ATF couldn't
answer basic questions about they didn't
want which is typical that is a normal
thing to see when you're in when you see
Congress people interrogating people
that are in are in the regulatory body
the ATF that is charged with regular
regulating
firearms and they know nothing there
there wasn't it was like someone asked
him he's like you don't know the
difference between 556 and 300 Blackout
this is like the ATF director yeah the
director of ADF did this thing and they
were like defined in 15 seconds for me
an assault weapon and he was like well
I'm not a gun expert so I can't and one
of my favorite tweets that came out here
was I think was a guy named George
Costas he said he doesn't know anything
about Firearms I'm glad he admitted that
does he know a lot about alcohol and
tobacco what is this guy doing yeah
right yeah it's like name your favorite
booze oh look I'm not a drinker I don't
know like well I am not an expert that's
the kind of person uh Budweiser should
hire though that's right gosh and then
tobacco that's just but he's also can we
get rid of this agency it makes no sense
there's a problem with that there's
actually a problem
because I was talking to someone at the
ATF a few weeks ago you know an inside
man just getting some information and
we're they don't like the FBI nobody
likes the FBI I don't think anyone in
America if you were sitting in a bar and
a guy you said hey what do you do for
work and he said I'm worth the FBI
if an FBI agent comes to me like I'm
with the FBI to go oh yeah X-Files I beg
really tell me everything yeah that guy
who's in bones and helps her with her
cases he's cool yeah but do you have the
FBI agents we like I guess the average
American will thank an FBI agent for
their service they're not going to do
that not right now but uh so I was
talking to my ATF guy and uh we were
talking about
um shoot where was I going uh the brace
thing where we just talk about polishing
the ATF abolish ATF and I and so I asked
him about that and he said well the
problem with the ATF going away is the
FBI would take over
resources they're weaponized way more
easily by the administration like
technically it's they've been trying to
weaponize the ATF for political means
and it's they put through an executive
order I think in 2021 it's still not in
effect this year that's how slow moving
the ATF is which is good for us like I
actually don't mind that's pretty cool
so my my tweet was essentially the ATF
should get removed when the gun laws are
removed at the same time so the FBI
can't do anything Squirrely and weird
and as long as you're I mean it's not
really that tall of an order to get rid
of federal gun laws because the federal
government doesn't have extensive gun
laws thanks to the Second Amendment
there's really limits placed on what the
feds can actually but here here's here's
the most important question the ATF has
just
imposed a rule yep without without
Congress making it illegal to own an
item attached to to a weapon that will
make what hundreds of thousands of
people criminal billions millions and
millions and millions I can't remember
what that number was it was like three
three we uh we we I I had to have them
uh because I think I have a handful of
pistols with braces they're all removed
and separated and stored somewhere far
away I just got Bob stocks and
everything man
but so but but with that are you still
allowed to have them so long as they're
not attached uh no the whole bumps out
things okay this is oh they lost that
they lost it right but no one knows like
it's in limbo and like will the company
starts selling them again no probably
not because they're like well they'll
just ban it the court struck that down
that is correct and the the brace thing
is going to be the exact same thing
they're going to fight it for two years
the issue is for resellers like gun
broker for example the day that went out
or the next day that went out they
pulled all those things of guns with
braces off of their website let's let me
provide people with some context real
quick just because it may be a little
bit esoteric for a lot of people and
there are uh pistols and there are
people who are disabled in order to fire
the pistol they attach a brace which
goes onto your forearm so you can hold
it however some of they they can adjust
in length they're retractable and so
some people and they and these are bad
people I tell you horrible they push
that up to their shoulder to simulate a
stock because a brace can simulate a
stock they've now made it illegal or
they've just issued short build rifle
yeah essentially they've decreed it now
that's that's the biggest problem I have
I've said on the show I was like come on
we know people are using braces like
stocks it's like everyone right right
everybody knows but and so I if first of
all I disagree with all the gun control
but if it went through Congress I'd roll
my eyes I'd complain about it but this
is a hundred times worse agency a rogue
agency issuing a rule we hereby decree
that if you have this thing you're a
felon that's crazy yep and the and the
issue is most people aren't following
the news I mean they just don't want to
they want to go about their life work
their job do whatever they don't know
what's going on with every regulation
and then all of a sudden a dude will get
caught up and it'll be like well I
didn't know it got changed I didn't
realize y'all were changing laws every
three years and regulations
right yeah but they said braces are fine
like you can do this thing they you know
SB sent this product to them they said
that's fine and so everyone bought them
and then oh you're going to change your
mind on it and go back on it and that's
going to screw over all the people that
don't pay attention to loss because I
mean I have a hard time paying attention
I literally do this for a job keeping up
with all the regulations I mean I'm
probably a felon five days out of the
week if I if I didn't cover the news
there's no way I would have known about
this yeah and so sure enough when the
news comes out it's like okay we got to
go and I think I think I like three and
we we took them off and we moved them
and stored them somewhere else I mean I
am you know I'm a guy that shoots a lot
and I pay a lot of attention to guns and
I'm you know active in the gun world and
at least enough to be aware of what's
going on and to think that the average
person is going to do that kind of stuff
when they've got they've got a family
they've got work they've got kids
they've got all an election coming up
they're like what do I do it's like
they're they're normal people with
normal lives and that's something that I
think a lot of people that that are are
wrapped up in this kind of stuff don't
realize you're average person doesn't
spend their days paying attention to the
details about what you know what laws
are passed or whatever and when you can
go to you know you can go to like
Runnings in New England there's this
this uh it's essentially Tractor Supply
that sells guns as well but you can buy
a you know a 10 inch pistol or you could
buy a 10 inch pistol and you know some
dude just goes and he's like oh I can
pick this up for 1500 bucks go home and
I shoot it once in a while that doesn't
watch guntube stuff and he doesn't know
that he's now a felon or he's going to
be a felon or whatever you see uh you
know that's ridiculous you said a viral
video of that gen Z Democrat where he
was like we're coming for your Gods
we're gonna win we're gonna take them
we're not safe
to invite them in your house no no he's
hired by the White House no no I was
gonna say you should invite him to your
house I'll take him to the range I mean
I'll have to have some people there so I
don't get like Chris Kyle but I tweeted
uh they already lost ooh the the gun
control people oh yeah not only are we
looking at 27 constitutional carry
states I think Nebraska our necks to go
into effect but 3D printed guns exist
it's done there's nothing they can do
about it the the uh the well I won't say
what I was gonna say I was going to say
ammo so they try to go off your ammo a
few years ago green tip ammo
um that's honestly yes the steel
penetrator uh it's all right it's not
that great but um but it works but they
tried to go after ammo and the thing
that gun control you know people could
do if they were if they were smart is
they would go after
um they would use OSHA compliance and
they would try to shut down businesses
and make it harder for businesses to
function businesses would have to raise
the prices to offset that I know but I'm
telling everyone who's on here who needs
to understand these things because I run
a business I can actually talk about
this
um that's how they could actually shut
down a lot of people from owning guns
and make it so only people in like the
six income you know six figure income
bracket could actually afford guns that
would be the way to do it because you're
they're not going to actually ban
weapons anytime soon but in States like
Washington I mean they just did and now
that's being fought so in some of the
really blue States like super blue
States
um I think we will see those bands like
at least be in effect for another 10 20
years until culture can shift and change
but nationally it's not going to happen
I just I just want to point out like
it's kind of amazing that we are winning
this this well like gun for one thing
yeah gun rights are winning so
tremendously it's like not even a
contest it's never been popular in
America no matter how much the media
says it's never been popular when you
get down to the individual level to take
guns away if you talk wait wait it
wasn't until I think like 2008 with uh
was it Heller in DC that then people
were actually able to have guns legally
Nationwide
good we had in the 80s Most states would
not give you a gun permit right you
couldn't have guns and then you watch
around the year 2000 constitutional
carry starts popping up state by state
and now it's 27 States yep so Nebraska
so it's 25 in effect Florida adjusted
permitless conceal carry Nebraska I
think would full constitutional am I
wrong just today I think it was and and
more coming it ain't over here more and
more states are going
the big the big Frontier is going to be
and the issue right now is the federal
government still controls who gets to
sell guns that is the whole FFL whole
thing the gun control act or whatever it
was that is the actual like the final
frontier of getting rights back is when
can States just get to do it on their
own you could have their own system for
choose that's an Amendment violation
yeah did States ever get to control who
who until I'm not up on my gun history I
think back in the day they took guns to
schools yeah
like people a lot of people that are
anti-gun will sit there and they'll say
well you never had this right you never
had that right etc etc but that's that's
essentially spinning reality on its head
because the idea that you were
prohibited was foreign to a free people
if you are by your nature free then the
idea that you don't have this right is
completely foreign to the concept of you
being free it comes with your Liberty
the fact that you're free means you
don't have to ask permission and that
doesn't matter what the context is you
know and it's so the idea that oh you
know you only the government is creating
this right and Etc no no no no no the
government doesn't create Liberties
Liberties exist and then the only thing
the government can do is infringe upon
those which the Second Amendment is
ostensibly supposed to prevent would
which it does a poor job of in my right
although it did help with the Bruin case
it did they did go back to that and go
hey according to this thing you know in
order to pass regulations you can't just
say it's for Public Safety because you
can't actually you can't argue that so
like you can't do it anymore the bump
stock thing that was that was a while
ago wasn't it they Struck it down uh I
think it was sort of struck down and
then it was kind of struck down again
because there was something about it
recently yeah again I didn't really pay
attention but like they're once again
legal yeah yes but I don't think anyone
will come out and start selling them or
putting in a gun broker or anything like
that because it's still kind of that
weird burnt child syndrome they're like
it's a my sock yep Trump Bandit don't
really want to do anything with it and
the same so the the real the real real
thing they're doing is when they say
pistol braces are banned people get rid
of them detach them stop selling them
out of the business and then they lose
and then people are like wow we don't
have any more yeah right businesses that
make them go under SB is probably I mean
I mean they haven't been able to sell
them for the last you know a couple
months so it's two months of Revenue
lost wow for three months whenever that
was
um and I had this conversation with them
they're the biggest brace the company
like that's literally how I got started
SP tactical and they said hey our goal
and this is what I really appreciate
about them they were actual zealots for
the cause and not just not just
capitalists but they're capitalists with
a conscience they said we would love to
put ourselves out of business by getting
sbrs taken off yeah so we don't have to
make these stupid things we'll pivot and
make stocks and we'll be fine so yeah
they they're probably uh two months out
of Revenue
um they're putting all their efforts
into the political fight there are
disabled people who can you who use them
yeah sure so you still do need pistol
braces yeah they'll make I mean
considering they definitely make a lot
less but not as much but yeah that's the
thing like the problem is
we will be honest about the fact that
people are using them as stocks I mean I
got tons of YouTube videos doing it so
the evidence is there and then but
because of that Honesty
our political Rivals will weaponize like
they will not be honest back they'll
they'll claim the AR-15 she needs to be
banned and then completely ignore every
other weapon and every other you know
whatever yeah well I think that I think
that's a lot of the issue it's my issue
and I've been speaking about this for
like the last six years is gun owners
sugarcoat like the modern the modern
sporting rifle is a perfect example
companies go well we can't call an M4 we
can't call it a weapon so we're going to
call it a sporting rifle and that right
there communicates to people that oh
this is a privilege not a right yeah
it's just a sporting instrument it's for
three gun or two gun or Shooting Sports
which people aren't when the M P 15 in
2020 the M P 15 was the best-selling
rifle in the nation an air 15 with a
front sight post 16 inch barrel people
were not buying those to shoot
competitions we did not see a rise in
Shooting Sports USPSA multi-gun three
gun when all those rifles for getting
bought that's not why people are buying
them but companies go we're going to
call it a sporting rifle so that we get
some heat taken off of us but all that
does is communicate to Gun Owners this
is a privilege not a right and it's
going to cause issues and I've literally
told companies like they've asked me hey
what should we do to modernize our brand
a little bit and I just go dump that
name get rid of it it's doing more harm
than good long term it might be fine
right now but in 10 years what's it
going to do to the culture and how
people view guns yep let's jump to this
next story which is not about guns but
is about the Department of Justice from
The Tennessean doj challenges
Tennessee's ban on transgender care for
minors the first thing I want to say is
I take issue with the title of this
article so I'm going to rephrase it for
the sake of honesty
Department of Justice challenges
Tennessee's ban on child sex change
surgery I mean you laugh but like
language is a huge component of how the
left plays politics absolutely and this
is this is exactly what was banned they
don't want medications puberty blockers
hormones and surgery for children
so these children have to you know be
adults before making these decisions but
now that doj has announced that they are
going to under the 14th Amendment try
and block this ban from happening
they argue
sb1 the bill makes it unlawful to
provide or offer to provide certain
types of medical care for transgender
minors with diagnosed gender dysphoria
sb1's blanket ban prohibits potential
treatment options that have been
recommended by Major Medical
associations for consideration in
limited circumstances in accordance with
established and comprehensive guidelines
Etc et cetera by denying only
transgender youth access to these forms
of medically necessary care while
allowing non-trion transgender minors
access to the same or similar procedures
what there's all you did you catch that
but let me read it it discriminates
against transgender youth the doj is
arguing that non-trans kids are
undergoing sex change surgery well if
that's the case we got bigger problem
than just this one bill there are
caveats and most evils including
Tennessee's that say children who were
born with a you know genetic defect they
don't identify a chance there's
literally something wrong there intersex
there's another issue at play they can
get hormonal treatment or something like
that but those people are not in the
same sphere as I'm not sure right and
it's it's determined by very much by
their genetics and their biology as
opposed to their psychological condition
like how often does that I mean and I
don't know I haven't studied this how
often does that actually happen you know
we talking like a 0.000 rare I mean it's
very uncommon it makes sense intersex
kids or kids who are born with like xxy
I think it's like .0017 or something but
it makes sense to permit them
finishingly small right but they want to
use that to argue well we should do it
for every one it's like well now that
we're seeing tens of thousands of kids
undergoing procedures of some sort uh
over the past few years it's getting
into like this I think it's 60 or so
thousand we went over this when Destiny
was here yeah 40 some odd thousand
taking hormone cross-sex hormones or
puberty blockers and then it's in the
thousands of uh uh teenage girls who are
getting mastectomies can you imagine if
a country uh foreign Europe they're
banning it if a foreign country in the
future say in 10 years and we've got
just all this stuff going on it's like
we're gonna invade America to free the
oppressed and get rid of this stuff
that's destroying kids and a foreign
Nation wanted to invade us over that
wouldn't that be fascinating you know if
I was going to look at history and
you're going to look at an invasion or
something if a foreign Invader let's say
it was like I don't know
if European nation sure we'll call it
like a water uh call it Germany they're
good at it let's just say there's like
let's just say there's like a big land
mass in the in in Europe and it started
by water and then maybe there's like a
smaller landmass to the west and then
people from One go to the other and then
say like you can't have kids anymore and
you can't speak your language one way to
you know get rid of that lineage just to
stop them from having kids avoiding
their kids or sterilizing their kids yep
that's one thing so when I see this this
is why I keep saying like it really does
feel like Democrats hate their own
constituents because like if you went to
someone and said have you considered
sterilizing your children it sounds like
you're insulting them I think there's a
deep nihilism that comes from most of
the philosophies that come from the left
I think that there is a a real
significant dislike of humanity the
whole uh environmental movement I feel
like is anti-human
um a lot of the left I feel like is
anti-human so it it when you say stuff
like that it doesn't sound like you're
talking about something crazy it's it
fits right in with my kind of concept of
the way the left thinks you know it
comes from the same sphere of uh
Humanity that produces articles that's
like here are 30 women who talk about
why they regret having children and it's
like selfish reasons I will point out
that how great my abortion was yeah
exactly like it you don't want to be
with these people anyways but I will
point out that the the doj sued Alabama
for similar reasons Alabama has uh
Senate Bill uh 184 and it's effectively
very similar right it's restricting the
medical procedures that you can offer
children who identify as transgender and
they classify it as part of their push
to prevent a gender-based discrimination
and I find this to be such a blatant
show of activism they sued Alabama in
April of 2022 and you can't you have to
wonder like
who is backing this like can you I guess
like I have never really liked the
federal government so it's easy for me
to say like we should let the states
regulate on their own but on the left
are you really that interested in
authoritarianism where you can have a
justice department that just actively
tries to selectively push its agenda
like at what point does that become
appealing to someone when you're growing
up when do you start thinking like you
know what I really want a really strong
central government that promotes a uh an
ideology that destroys children I don't
think that the government I think the
government is uh is a necessary from
their perspective the government is a
necessary evil to achieve the ends that
they're looking for and they don't think
about the fact that when you empower the
government it's you never you know just
continues to amass power it's not going
to give power back so
seems crazy to me the other part that I
find interesting is that the the doj put
out the statement saying like this is a
terrible thing to do especially for
transgender identifying youth or they
say transgender youth but uh who are
already at risk of suicide depression
Etc and then the Tennessee uh uh
attorney general his office put out
statement saying like actually no this
is not a conform a confirmed way to
treat children in fact having them go
through these treatments can increase
suicide anxiety and depression and so
they're at this Crossroads where you
know we really don't know what to do
with this issue and so you can kind of
argue the same thing and end up on
different ends same screen two different
movies like Scott Adams says Lucas I
mean you're from Tennessee do you is
there an app a significant appetite for
this stuff around Nashville do you feel
like there's a lot of people that are
like so or does it seem like this stuff
is coming out of nowhere and there's not
like a lot of support for it it does
seem like something that comes out of
nowhere uh I'm not a real big conspiracy
theorist but what when all this stuff
came is you know is being talked about
none of this is shocking to me and the
reason this isn't shocking to me is for
the last 50 years it's everyone has been
been desensitized to being okay with
murdering babies I did something like 63
million I think is what I wrote down I
was doing some research earlier today 63
million babies have been aboard in the
last 50 years just here in our country
wow so over 50 years people have been
desensitized to it's okay it's
acceptable we can do it at four weeks
six weeks eight weeks um I think someone
was telling me it was either the West
Virginia governor a couple years ago was
saying after uh after the baby was born
or was Virginia governor Virginia and um
and so with all this trans stuff about
kids if if people don't value their
children before they're born why would
they value their children but the
abortion thing is important to point out
the 63 million it was probably like 63
million Democrats you know what I mean I
mean but I mean but but you know it's
not meant to be snide or rude or funny
sure to make the point like
those are the people doing it that's 63
million votes gone in 20 years the
Democratic party yeah and that means
that the the politics around abortion is
going to change no questions I mean
people on the right side yeah but
they're trying to adapt and doctrinate
our kids and I'm like yes but you're
aware of that
so as long as you're aware and you're
resisting it then right likelihood they
change they convert your kids into being
you know anti-baby well very low well
and the trans thing too I mean I've only
seen a few um you know stories come out
of of kids afterwards who say they
regret you know you read it it's a lot
honestly it's probably the most sad
depressing thing I ever see are the
stories of those kids were like I can
never get this back I made this decision
or my parents had me make this decision
I can't do anything and I feel like oh
in the next like five years those are
gonna blow up there's going to be a lot
more of those or the suicide rates going
to go up even more so at what point are
people really going to ask the question
or are they going to squish all those
stories we just keep doing it we've seen
it before I mean we we've had there have
been practices that have been banned
lobotomies are banned they they would go
to people and say I think the
appropriate treatment for your child is
for us to remove a portion of their
frontal lobe through their nose or
something like that and then they would
turn their kids into zombies wasn't
there like a Kennedy yeah it's Rosemary
Kennedy she's the first daughter so it
was Joe John and then Rosemary and she
had they believe like didn't have enough
oxygen when she was born she always had
add some sort of brain disorder and it
became progressively worse and her
parents eventually heard like hey
there's this cool new treatment it might
be able to help and they were desperate
I mean I think everyone looking back
recognizes how wrong they were but when
you don't have the information I could
understand right yeah but even then
there was enough I mean I think at the
time when she had her lobotomy it was
only like a hundred people had undergone
them which like she already seems like
too many but again if you didn't know
and if they're as they were
misrepresenting the results of these
things I mean I understand wanting to
help we love and especially if you're
desperate but I think it's obvious in
this case that waiting is the best
course of action right offering other
forms of therapy and really discussing
with your child like what's going on is
so much safer than saying take these
drugs alter your body well and I also
feel like I saw a video I think it was
Jordan Peterson you posted earlier today
of and and this obviously isn't
happening for everyone but it's probably
happening more than people want to admit
there was this a a bunch of tick tock
videos of his dad with his trans
daughter and the report was that he was
using her for uh likes and attention
yeah and uh that right there uh it has
all sorts of problems with it but I I
would be curious how many parents are
doing going through with this to keep up
with the Joneses yeah it is now the new
thing oh yeah my kids trans too yours is
too hey I'm doing this you know and I
mean it's just a pawn Bill Barr mentions
it we're seeing it in California but not
Ohio so either there's something
happening in the water in Colorado in
California or they're they're
socializing their kids this way well and
during covid when uh students went home
there were all these anecdotal reports
about we used to have you know six
identifying uh trans identifying
students and now it's only one of them a
bunch of them decided when they were
home with their families that they
didn't actually feel this way right like
of course the anecdotal I'd love to see
hard numbers on it but there is
something to be said for the social
contagion aspect of it I think you're
totally right I missed the days of the
tiger mom when it's like all these women
trying to make their kids be the best of
whatever like instead of trying to make
your kid a different gender can't you
just like stress them out about getting
good grades not that that's a healthy
way to pair it but yeah Let's uh let's
move on to this story that I really
don't want to talk about but kind of
feel like we have to yasher Ali
journalist published footage from
Stephen Crowder's home with his wife
because they're going through a divorce
and I don't think this should be uh
published I think yashar Ali was wrong
to publish this I don't think it should
be discussed but the issue is the the
videos got half a million views the
Tweet itself I think has two million
views so I'm interested in talking about
to a certain degree what it is because
it is a thing people are watching but
more so the ethics of why this should
not be a thing and how I think it's
being weaponized against Stephen Crowder
so to put it simply there's a few big
stories right now one you may have seen
Stephen Crowder put out a video where he
said that he's going through a divorce
it's horrendous and that he I think he
said he's being extorted is that what he
said
he implied right did he say extorted or
he said if you know what extortion is
like this is what it feels like or
something like that now the media Daily
Beast reports Stephen Crowder's
extortion war with Candace Owens is it
blows up and I'm wondering how is it
that Stephen Crowder's divorce has
become some something for like yeah sure
to publish why is it news it's it's
ridiculous because I hate Stephen
correct because the left hates Stephen
Crowder and so this is a huge
opportunity for them to attack him to
accuse him of wrongdoing and then you
get this video
this video that I'm not going to play
um I know a lot of people want me to
play it people were commenting like you
got to play the video people are mad at
Crowder dude I will not fall for a 20
second out of context clip I'm not
playing that game that's what I want to
say about this to everybody who's seen
this video you've got Stephen Crowder's
wife she's very pregnant they're arguing
I guess over a car or something like I
was surprised to learn that Crowder his
family has one car
or supposedly supposedly
exactly exactly because like when I hear
the story that Crowder's fighting with
his wife because he wants to use the car
and he doesn't want her to use the car
I'm kind of like maybe they have maybe
the other cars in the shop maybe but
Crowder seems like the kind of guy who
would have three maybe four or five cars
maybe a collection he doesn't want to
tell anyone about yeah no I mean more
than you know but uh what I want to say
about the uh the video clip is a few
questions one how did yasher Ali get
three minutes of video footage of
crowder quote being emotionally
emotionally abusive to his wife from it
Crowder's house from Crowder's house so
who is recording this they have a ring
camera in there I mean this is crazy
audio and video record in his house and
what what bothers me about this is man
I'm reluctant to say what I think but I
think Crowder is being set up just I
mean he wouldn't post that footage right
himself that means somebody knew the
footage was available shared it with the
press and
who could that have been I mean it it is
like it is possible that someone at ring
but I mean I do I think that I think I
think all right dude I'm just gonna say
it come on man who do you think his wife
yeah he's getting divorced so who who
and he said it's become increasingly
hostile like I wonder if this is
actually something that got submitted to
the court I don't want to accuse I don't
know that she did I'm just saying
Crowder in this video
he's not gonna release that footage no
if it was if it was hacked footage
either of them I would assume would be
upset by that I would say it or they
might both say it be like hey we're
having issues but our cameras in our
home where our children we're hacked
where our children are like this is an
issue we're gonna Sue ring and it's
going to be a thing like but I don't
think that's happened never said that no
no
I want to say something too that's kind
of crazy is people are acting like this
video is really bad and it's it's not
so uh basically his wife says write an
impasse I love you but I need some time
and then she's she accused him she says
something about his abuse and he says
watch it watch it and like that's
basically it and I'm like I don't know
what I'm supposed to be mad about
they're just people want to be mad they
want to be mad and it's actually
impossible to judge because you we don't
know them like we don't know them on
this level I mean it's it's something
that I think as a culture especially
women are increasingly aware of like you
need to be careful about the Dynamics
you put yourself in and like I do know
people who have been in really
controlling relationships where like
only having one car is a part of that
but I don't know the Crowders well
enough to have any context to believe
that's where this comes from right like
it's it's I think hard not to read and
you have to be careful not to read your
own experience into it like if you have
been in a dangerous situation you might
see it but if you haven't you may not it
doesn't mean like it's hard to know what
it is I remember I was I was hanging out
with some friends of mine this is
probably like six years ago and I heard
how they talked to each other and I was
like man I don't know if I I like that
I'm not gonna talk to my wife that way
and then over the years since I got to
know I was like oh this is kind of how
they joke around with each other and say
stuff now I'm not saying that's what's
happening here but like a lot of people
especially people accommodating on this
are they married they're in a
relationship what they're talking about
yeah they've experience you know I'll
probably end up I'll probably get in
trouble to some degree for saying my
opinions on this because I I think it's
a stupid story that shouldn't be
published but
when I see camera footage released
that's got a 20 second clip that makes
someone like Crowder look bad and then I
I'll just put it this way
if there was a recording of say like
let's say Phil Labonte was accused of
wrongdoing and then also the recording
emerges and I'm like hello there Phil
tell me about that time you bought
illegal drugs and then feels like what
are you talking about you know the
illegal drugs you bought tell me you'd
kind of assume that someone was
intending on that recording existing for
purposes of of implicating another
person so when I see this and again
Without accusing anybody because I don't
know when I see this and someone says
let me tell you about your abuse Stephen
I'm like hey are you what do people talk
like that like it's a very specific
thing to say to someone and then Crowder
clearly reacts negatively to it he says
watch it and then he says effing watch
it
and my response to that is like dude if
someone walks up to me in my room and
accused me of something as serious as
that I might be like excuse me no get
out like I'm not having that
conversation because that's not true
that's not fair what are you saying
worse still
somebody leaked the footage to yasher
Ali yeah
yeah I I mean anything I at this point
with the way the culture war is going
anybody that is a a prominent figure on
the right it is every opportunity that
that someone on the left can take to
cannot to knock you down or to to smear
you yeah they're going to take it's
something that people that are are oh
yeah you know that are on the right that
they have to be aware of oh okay so so
fair point people are mentioning that's
a Twitter clip there's a three minute
clip and he says a lot worse things he
says I'm gonna F you up and so you know
Fair Point like he should not have done
that right I think I haven't watched the
full thing yeah I haven't watched it I
think it's really hard because
saying really nasty things one time like
does that constitute being an abusive
person or is it just you lost control in
this one moment right like we have no
way to know what the pattern of their
relationship is and that's why it's hard
to see this stuff online because like
they have children the internet is
forever is this one terrible fight for a
couple that's already falling apart or
is this a pattern of behavior that it's
hard for the public to wrap their heads
around because he is a public figure
well this could be another issue of I
mean often not always but in
relationships it's not always just one
person at fault it can be both people
are at fault kind of like how Wars
happen it's not always a good guy and a
bad guy sometimes it's just two kind of
bad guys duking it out so I I just think
that's a whole nother again there's just
not enough context to know but I also
know I mean this is maybe a little bit
of personal experiences I'm ready for
two years now being in a position like
he's in of constant criticism under a
microscope at all times like that can
put stress on a marriage I I want to
stress this too I didn't watch the three
minute I didn't realize Joshua released
the entire three and a half minutes I
watched clip on Twitter and when I
opened up the article on my phone the
video wasn't there like I didn't see the
video there until just now so that's my
mistake so I apologize for that he snaps
at her saying watch it effing watch it I
will F you up which led to his wife
fleeing their home so like I think it's
bad and I'm just I'm like
the the issue I take with it is it's
personal private stuff if Crowder did
wrong he's paying the price for it
they're the only reason it's news is
because Crowder is a prominent figure
who's challenging The Establishment and
they know that they can they can take
him down with something like this
they've been waiting for something like
this if Crowder did something wrong in
this moment he should he should
apologize for being wrong and and doing
a wrong thing make things right to her
but the purpose of this is to cause
political and PR damage to a prominent
individual who is challenging the
machine it's just a smear it's pure
culture War it's just smearing Crowder
because he's on the right that's all it
is it's unfortunate but that's that's
the the yeah it's the world and it
doesn't make like the way he's talking
to her okay it just means if he were a
private citizen it would still be wrong
okay this happens
this is happening a thousand other times
in America somewhere else with other
people all over no one will know about
talk about don't care yeah they only
care because it's him and her absolutely
absolutely
I'm sorry I just feel bad for their kids
right because like oh yeah obviously
this seems contentious and horrible
divorce is so difficult for children as
it is but like how many kids they have I
don't know do they uh well she's
pregnant yeah like there's one on the
way there's a lot of really serious
accusations in here and like my view is
just this I don't I don't care to
condemn someone because a clip even the
three minute three and a half minute one
I read the quote where he said that and
stuff like that and it's like
man
to take three minutes of someone's life
and then condemn them over that without
knowing everything else
unless there was like serious like let's
say he got up and started beating that'd
be different because then it'd be like
okay
that's like one of the issues that so
many people have about abuse like the
way people talk about abuses because
like if like someone punched me in the
face right we would all agree that's
been not okay but if you are constantly
in a place where you're like in fear
because of the way you're being treated
the way you're talking to it like being
talked to stuff like that like that is
psychologically damaging it's just much
harder to analyze like in some ways we
wish abuse was more clear-cut and like
in this case like we just don't have the
context to know what's going on that's
why it's like I wish this wasn't out
here I wish we weren't we didn't have to
talk about it or address it because like
I would never
I don't think you can accurately
um prescribe what's going on from three
minutes if it is a really toxic Dynamic
I hope both of them get help and if it's
this was just a bad moment I again I
have to reiterate like they have
children this will live on forever and
that's who's suffering the most from all
of this yep and they'll both and the
issue here too is they'll both be
bothered by it they go through with the
divorce she goes somewhere else people
will always know her as the woman in
this clip and he'll always be known as
the dude in this clip so they're they're
both screwed over it I don't see it I
don't see how there's a winner by by
releasing this uh I even if if whether
it be it could help with a lawsuit
potentially or
um Divorce Court well I mean having it
would but like putting it out and it
doesn't you know having yeah sure put it
out it doesn't uh it doesn't does I
don't see how how there's any unless
it's like a moment of anger right like
we really think she leaked it and she's
like the way you said your statement
makes it sound like this was something I
did and you're the victim and I feel
like I suffered I mean it's not an okay
way to handle it in my opinion but again
it's my opinion I did not have to be
involved with any of this and I again I
just think that like these videos last
forever and their kids are going to
inevitably Google themselves and this
will come up people are saying like
don't defend Stephen blah blah I'm like
bro I have seen so many video videos
from protests or of people being who are
like supposedly innocent being beaten by
cops or whatever and then the full video
comes out and so I'm just saying like
I'm not saying Steven's perfect he
probably has to apologize for a lot okay
and that's fine but the the the fact is
this is being weaponized by people who
just want to take down Stephen Crowder
for political reasons well if all of us
examined ourselves I mean I know there
have been Knights that I've neglected my
wife not done things for her and if
there were Clips posted of me sitting at
my computer gaming and not spending time
with her people could be like whoa look
how selfish Lucas is playing video games
and not spending time with his wife
we're still how many of us are guilty of
similar things how about this what if
you were playing video games with your
wife and you're saying stuff like if I
catch you you will kill you yeah yeah
right I can't believe he said that and
that's like your wife's laughing and
she's like oh and you know exactly but
context it matters too what I don't like
about this video
is I just
the question of who leaked it yep and if
the if it was leaked is this like was
someone aware that they were having a
recording created and they said things
you know what I mean just like imagine
if you walked up to somebody who trusted
you and didn't think that you would leak
a recording of them or whatever and then
they said something to you intentionally
to make you angry that you knew wasn't
true and there's nothing you can say
like like if if I want to film was like
I know you stole my bike you'd be like
what and then you have a negative
reaction to it then someone leaks the
footage being like when Tim confronted
Phil over stealing his bike Phil freaked
out and got really angry yeah right
right wouldn't you be angry if someone
accused you of abusing them if you if
you didn't do it you know what I mean
like so I'm gonna F you up like it's not
something
I'm not saying he's innocent at all I'm
just saying like
critical thinking skills
I didn't I didn't have this even slated
for tonight until everyone was like
super chatting and asking about it and
I'm like the problem I see here is that
everyone's jumping the gun and
immediately just attacking Crowder over
this and it's like okay like I'll say it
again
innocent until proven guilty it doesn't
look good but it's also none of our
business yeah is there a date on this
video I think yes I think it was uh 2021
yeah oh this doesn't make again it
doesn't make the exchange better at all
but like it makes me wonder like you
know if you realize that you're in a
terrible Dynamic with someone like do
you do work do you so you got a priest
or a therapist like how do you work
through these things and like at what
point like we'll never know the context
of what's going on or what afterwards so
June 26 2021
so so they have twins and yeah so I
don't I don't want to get too in depth
on on making uh making assumptions about
this
um because of my experience and because
of people close to me's experience with
uh
abusive partners and stuff I'm gonna
leave it at this like if you're in a
situation where you feel like you are
being abused just get out of it like
just leave
um our guitar player has passed away and
leading up to his death there was a lot
of abuse in his relationship uh
if if you're in a situation just leave
just leave this is worry about telling
people don't worry about stories just
get out of it I want to add one thing
like what
I don't like seeing videos on the
internet that are like a short snippet
and then condemning someone I like
evidence that's what I did with the
Covington kids but I also am aware that
the left has this technique this trick
where they'll start filming and then
they'll go why did you just do this
thing why did you just call me this slur
why did you just hit me and you don't
actually see the thing happen you just
see them saying why did you do it and
the other person is yelling and they're
like aha here's a video of a person who
did X yeah so it's just like
sorry man what can you believe anymore
yep well apparently people are saying uh
the wife released it but he said that
Crowder was lying about the situation
yeah I just I don't know why why would
the wife release it
is it because like she's not a public
figure
yeah but maybe that's what she's like
unhappy about like she feels like she
suffered and now Stephen's getting to
say like this wasn't my choice I didn't
want to get divorced and she's like you
didn't attend to our marriage the way
you should have I'm just speculating I
don't actually know I don't want to I
guess one thing that Yasha reports is
that Crowder actually got a divorce
lawyer like in advance or something but
he's I just I know money that makes
sense to me I find it all very suspect I
really do you know Crowder Crowder is a
person that they've been desperate to
get rid of for a very very long time
he's extremely prominent and effective
when it comes to messaging and humor and
and building culture he's the only
competition for like well Gutfeld now
but for a while it was the only
right-leaning competition to late night
comedy or or like morning talk shows I
am not saying he is innocent I'm just
saying it gives me pause and makes me
you know I I'm I find it suspicious well
and there are a lot of people who have
chaotic personal lives who can do good
right like it doesn't make the messaging
and like the the entertainment value and
the things that he has done to like
introduce people to all kinds of
important ideas less valuable it just
means that he is a flawed person but so
is everyone at the end of the day yeah
but nobody it's it's tough like I know
I've mistreated people in relationships
and and even people at work and then
also my wife neglecting her whatever and
I think a lot of people just are
unwilling to acknowledge that and they
want to go judge everyone else's
lifestyle instead of going oh am I
actually making some of the same
mistakes and that I think that's a lot
of the problem and a lot of the reason
they want to go after someone like
Crowder are other people who are having
issues with their their own life is so
that they can prop themselves up and
feel good especially I'm not doing that
I think it's best like no you're
actually doing that in another way you
just won't but but people are saying
it's Crowder's fault he brought this up
it's like
um maybe the reason Crowder brought it
up was because his wife gave the video
footage to journalists and to Native
felons and he knew it and he was like
there's nothing I can do about it now
they're going to publish this footage so
I'll get in front of it now people are
acting like that's proof they had no
choice but to release the footage and
give a statement because Crowder brought
it up and it's like if this has been
going on for two years and Crowder
didn't say anything at all ever until
yasher Ali like right was about like was
just about to publish the story it kind
of lends itself to they took this move
against Crowder not the other way around
yeah it's just yeah it's sad all around
yep
I don't know does this mean that you
know you guys in the chat are going to
stop watching Stephen Crowder or
something
some people probably want to boycott him
probably yeah I mean I imagine so but I
don't imagine that is I don't imagine
that is that his audience is gonna I
mean it depends on what comes out if
it's if it's bad mouthing and fighting
and and you know bitterly arguing with
his wife people probably won't leave him
like high and dry they'll just be like
okay you were kind of crappy just as
long as it's not too grossly offensive
if it comes out that he was doing you
know other kind of things that that kind
of Cross Physical lines or whatever then
you might lose it all sure well this is
kind of going back to the first topic of
conversation with uh Budweiser
um if there if there was some stuff
going on and now this is public
for PR but I also think just from a
moral standpoint
um if Crowder just did a video going hey
I'm sorry you all had to see my personal
life and what happened yes I'm imperfect
yes I did some of these things we're now
trying to part ways as well as we can
and et cetera et cetera and he did a
video you know coming forward and
explaining the situation and apologizing
for any wrongdoing that he did because
he probably did at some level especially
I imagine if the video you know based on
the video uh I think a lot of people
would go oh okay thank you um you're
transparent you're being genuine and
real that's what they want Budweiser to
do here's what here's what I'm going to
choose to believe I'm gonna I'm gonna I
mean this as a joke by the way that uh
after Crowder came after the daily wire
Jeremy boring can stand and he's like
and then he's like pull out all the
stops it's time for my room
and then like Candace and Michael
Knowles are there and Matt Walsh and
they're like we're at your disposal
Jeremy and he's like I want dirt on this
guy whatever you can find I'm kidding
call and call out my buddy at uh Amazon
so that way I can get his ring cam right
like cloud-based cameras and we all
floated like was it a hack like the fact
no no apparently they're saying that uh
I guess Candace said it was the wife it
was yeah that's the simplest explanation
but I'm just anti-amazon ring cameras
and I feel like this is a good moment to
put that in there yeah I just all the
way when someone is on camera and
they're like Phil that time you struck
me was wrong and then you're like what
are you talking about don't deny it now
you're proving it and then I and then
the footage gets released and it's like
oh wow look at this Phil looks really
really bad I'm just kind of like you
know she walks up to him and she says
he's abusing her and then gives the
footage to someone it's kind of like
15 minutes ago there was a 38 Chinese
warplanes and six vessels of the
people's Liberation Army Navy detected
around Taiwan timing Taiwanese defense
Ministry says but what does that have to
do with Crowder getting divorced I don't
know
I'm sorry classic China breaking news on
a Friday by the way yeah right
is more important you know that I just
saw that and it's where did you see that
story uh inside Insider paper they are
verified uh so that means they have
eight dollars and uh
259 fall five 259 000 followers do
people trust people more with blue check
marks still do you think I don't think
so yeah I don't think so because now you
can buy one but also I'm not seeing the
story it was arbitrary about who got it
like you had to be it people definitely
respected it back then like for sure but
remember that was at Twitter's
discretion like if they liked you you
would get one I get that it had like a
symbolic all right this is just breaking
right now 38 we're playing six vessels
of people's Liberation Army Navy
detected around Taiwan Taiwanese defense
Ministry says
well I mean okay it's the waiting I
can't stand so
especially you know I actually thought
they would make the moves closer to the
election because it would be more
chaotic uh during elections the
president is limited in what they can or
can't do because they're so distracted
no it's not just that it's that if if if
there's a person there's cons if Joe
Biden reacted decisively and took action
people might cheer for it but if he
screws up he's done for and it'll put
someone else in power so it ties their
hand behind their their hands behind
their back yeah yeah I don't know maybe
maybe we're sitting here uh talking
about stupid culture War drama nonsense
and uh China's about to invade Taiwan
world war three starting right
yeah how many times have we said world
war three started by now I think it's
like eight years maybe 16. I think the
pope said world war three started
Russian media says world war three
social medias has been on it for a while
it started dying for it they're really
hoping as well yeah but I don't know I'm
not not seeing much more on this one so
me neither I'm sorry that could be a
fault it could also no I mean this is
being reported inside papers reporting
it right
so
we'll see I guess
but hey I don't know how about how about
this little tidbit Vice news is gone
to make you nostalgic to him it breaks
my heart it breaks my heart Vice news
tonight formally shut down and I just
think it's funny that you've got these
Vice news staffers that are like to the
to the original crew that helped launch
Vice news we changed the game blah blah
I'm like that's me he's like you know
you're talking about me right because
like you guys don't like me but you're I
was thinking of like retweeting them
being like thank you thank you thank you
for the compliment so for those that
don't know I was the first person hired
advice to start Vice news there was no
Vice news they hired me and then like
six months later they were like should
we create a news division like a brand
for this and then they did and I was uh
so they had news in the sense that Vice
would make documentaries and then it
would just they would say like it's a
news thing
and then eventually decided to launch a
specific brand called device news I was
the first person and so I brought new
methodologies new technologies and
Reporting Styles they then hired a bunch
of people I left after about a year and
a few months and then they went woke
real quick it was really creepy over
like like a year after I left the
company just went woke woke woke and it
was so weird because when I was there it
was like sex drugs and rock and roll
Tumblr was still around as soon as they
as soon as they got sex off of Tumblr
all the book stuff could have got
spilled out into the rest of the
internet like coming when you were there
a Dollar was just like absolutely not
and uh I mean there was corporatizing
you could feel that but apparently what
happened was a friend of mine who was a
higher up said that they had faced too
many sexual harassment lawsuits and so
the investors came to them and said the
only way out of this is to embrace
feminism
and they said you got it and that was
their defense against being sued for
sexual harassment and stuff
wow so the same advice and I don't fully
understand this Vice is just gone or is
vice still a thing but Vice news vice
vice news tonight is being canceled and
they're laying a bunch of people off so
they'll still have something called
device news but the main show that was
on TV for the past decade is gone
ah so is this the first TV show gone and
as the internet is taking over is that
what well no no it's just it won't go
broke they they burn themselves the
first show they had was called Vice and
uh it was amazing
the first the first show just Vice was
so good man Vice back in the day for
people who know it it was basically four
Dudes it was it was sarush it was Shane
it was uh who was the other guy
uh what's up no Gavin Gavin was gone at
this point they had four hosts of their
show I can't remember I can't remember
their names and then uh the show was
basically like weird travel stuff it was
traveling on the World to Crazy places
and exploring and then I guess what
happened was HBO wanted to cancel it and
so they announced abruptly before HBO
can re re-upped it that they were
already being renewed for a new season
which forced HBO's hand but then HBO
came back I don't know this is true this
is what I heard when I worked there
HBO came back and said how dare you and
they were like too bad you're locked in
now it's been announced to the press and
everyone's expecting it and so then HBO
was like if we're going to do it then
changes have to be made and here's the
best part I was told that I couldn't
host for them because I was a white dude
that doesn't seem racist at all oh my
goodness I was like but I'm actually
mixed race and they're like yeah but you
know you're a guy who looks too white
and so they were like you and you can
notice this too when you look at the
advice on HBO staff they bring in like
an Indian guy some women they brought in
a bunch of women and so when I had
joined them I said I want to be a an
honor host and I will bring my brand and
the work that I do and they agreed and
then sure enough
I asked them and they were like two
things one fair point I did not have
hosting experience for documentary so I
was doing like basically what I'm doing
now and they wanted more Pizzazz totally
fair so they had me host some stuff but
then when it came to HBO they said your
white dude have a nice day get lost they
didn't say it like that they're just
like look we've got a mandate they want
you know people of color and women but
they just straight up said it oh yeah
hands down I mean I was told the same
thing by Fusion when I worked there the
ABC News company when they did uh they
had the black and brown forum
and they brought in they had like three
of their senior Talent uh cat staff
talent and then One external guy and
this is like Hillary Clinton and Bernie
Sanders are being questioned by a panel
of journalists and so they just said
nothing to me and
so I go to the president and I was like
is there a reason you guys had the other
main talent and not me your like senior
reporter and and the guy goes oh he's
because it's racist because you're white
you literally told me that
and then I was like but I'm mixed he's
like yeah but come on man
and I was like I mean hey like the dude
was kind of cool I get it I mean he's
just a businessman that's what that's
just set it all up the uh uh makeup
artist for Tropic Thunder and you're
like do me up and I'm gonna go back in
there
that was so funny I was like okay
well all right then and when was that
how many years ago was that this is 26
2014 or 15. I think 2015 because it was
like the presidential election they
ranked Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton and they're going to be
questioned by people and it was called
the black and brown forum and then I was
like I guess being like Asian doesn't
count like I don't I don't count as like
part of this diverse America and and
keep in mind too because a lot of people
might want to say like Tim your politics
no no this is this is almost a decade
ago and I had no politics like I had
politics but I wasn't doing anything
like this my videos were all like I'm
here on the ground in Fukushima Japan
and there's radiation you were a
journalist that's all I was doing yeah
there was no like me coming in the
office and being like here's what I
think about the wage again if you're
talking about guns it was literally just
like oh I did it we I did a documentary
on police brutality and the Ferguson
riots and that and that was what I
worked on and then when it came to this
they outright said you look too white
you can't be involved and like that's
the world they wanted to create so get
what go good rid stalia if only your
genetics had uh
perform slightly
slightly slightly more Asian I mean
it sounds like it would have helped you
in this case anyway though in this case
being a more Asian wouldn't have helped
yeah yeah I think they don't like Asian
people no I mean it probably would have
it probably would have but I actually
lobbied to him I was like isn't it fair
to say that like a mixed race person is
is representative of a changing America
and should have a voice and he was just
like you look white dude you have to
like bring your grandma with you be like
no first real
like that's so weird Paul and Elizabeth
Warren and be like I'm actually this
well they would let her in no that's the
funny thing they'd be like welcome
please sit down tell us about your
native tribe but that's I think that's
why I can't stand all the woke people in
the in the in the race Theory stuff in
the ideology is because it's all it's
all lies it's all it's all just not true
Luke Rakowski is a person of color
he's got blonde hair and blue eyes
what's going on oh he's polish so he's
chillavic that's right but Asians over
perform so we don't count
and then I I'm mostly white so I just
ridiculous I mean you guys are good at
literally everything no matter what so
that is true that's right we make
gunpowder before you guys uh it's true
and the compasses yep
yeah whatever man good riddance to a bad
problem did you see that they just had
the state estate dinner with uh South
Korea and we invited all of our like
South Korean adjacent influencers like
mad at Maddox pidgeoli he went with his
mom Angelina and like Joanna Gaines was
there it made me very uncomfortable but
maybe people liked it I don't know
wait like the White House brought so
like the president of South Korea is
visiting so they have a state dinner and
they invite this is typical yeah like
when they had the uh Canadian one a
couple years ago Blake Lively and her
husband because he's Canadian got to go
and this time you know they always
invite some celebrities so it was like
Joanna Gaines who does the Waco you know
house stuff and she's she's also I don't
remember what percentage but she's also
of Korean descent and then Angelina
Jolie went with her son who is uh of
South South Korean descent and I think
he even lives there now I'm not totally
sure but it did feel a little bit like
weird I don't know maybe no one else
felt that way slightly right pandering
is the strategy nowadays I mean it's
what you have to do to survive well or
die I guess in this case yeah I don't
know I guess maybe they wouldn't invite
me to something like that because it
would be offensive to the Korean people
because they're the older generation are
very racial supremacists Joanna Gaines
what she's mixed but is she is she half
I don't know maybe because she passes as
Korean
but I think she can also pass his wife
yeah I feel like this is going to get
everybody's going to talk about this in
a way that's okay where you can pass
this two different and she brought her
white husband most most like most of my
life white people just assumed I was
Mexican it's like the way but for real
like the way my facial hair grows right
and they'd just be like you know they'd
be like oh you're actually the best of
all three worlds is what you're saying I
guess unless unless you're surrounded by
woke people who just don't don't want to
be dealing with what you are because in
their world if they can't Define You by
race they can't Define you at all
they're going to be verbally racist well
there's a solution you just have to be
trans and then you're at the top you're
the pin that's true if you do that
that's true yeah that is the meta
content move is to be like if I told you
my sexual preference would that put me
at the higher higher portion it's
probably a little I don't know like
right there they're like maybe it's like
you go to these meetings and they say
like hey you you Phil you you can't come
in here and then he goes what if I told
you my sexual preference oh I'm
listening
I'm Polly oh that puts you uh 50 15 yeah
that's so you uh you win you don't get
to hold but you do occasionally get to
be a future yes so it is funny so with
uh government Government Contracting
that is a thing like when there's a bid
out there for uh you know purchasing a
thing it's like if they're a female
owned business if they're veteran owned
if they're disabled and if they I
believe a race is another one so there
are companies that literally will pick a
CEO who can stack as many of these
things as possible to be the tiebreaker
for contracts well it's like it's
already a structure there's a good news
Tim cast is a minority-owned company oh
there you go boom actually can I add
that to our Google or whatever yes like
you know they rank us up because
you know had some pronouns as well so
you probably yeah put my pronouns in
there and then we'll get number one I
tried to put in a Apache helicopter
gunship on Instagram and it didn't let
me do that oh that's that's bigotry
right there it was all right everybody
we're gonna go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member by going to
timcast.com and clicking join us as a
member you'll get access to the Discord
server or you can hang out with
like-minded individuals if you are a
member for at least six months or you
sign up at the 25 per month level you
can submit questions and actually call
into the uncensored show and talk to us
we love taking your calls and we do that
uncensored show at about 10 10 P.M
Monday through Thursday so we'll have
one up for you tonight you don't want to
miss it let's read your super chats all
right Das ruse says so happy Lucas
showed up gwot vet here just found a
community here in Florida who trains
every Saturday we'll be training with
them and growing the two-way Community
down here for more free and self-reliant
Florida thanks Lucas awesome love to
hear it right on
sideways 2013 said so earlier my default
Democrat mom who voted Biden came to me
and was pissed about Biden putting
forward higher mortgage fees for people
with good credit to cover for bad credit
equality versus Equity there it is you
guys see that story yeah if you've got
bad credit your your costs go down
you've got good credit goes up unreal
communism is coming baby and it's gonna
suck and the people who suffer most are
the people in the middle of that yep
what do we got here John Kristen says
Lucas love the arrow 308 5K review video
any other 308 5K videos in the work
Works love to see one either for the Sig
716i or Ruger sfar
I no
um yeah that took a lot of time a lot of
energy uh it was not the 308 recoil that
was not the problem it was just so much
time to do that video but it will do
more is that normal for your gun review
videos does it take like so no I would I
wanted to shoot a rifle to 5000 rounds
and it's a 308 rifle so like it punches
a little bit but uh on a range day I can
efficiently only shoot maybe a thousand
rounds and so it's five film days plus
stuff in the middle so I mean we're
talking three weeks to finish one video
when a lot of content creators will do a
video in a day and I'm like I'm gonna
keep going out there so you know four
videos or one I do like eight per day
yeah because I just turned the camera on
I do not I I do not want your life I
don't want to be I don't know it's not
really easier
no every job my production is that I
read the news and then I complain about
it you know what I mean
yeah but what happens you know before
the show it's like ah what's there to
talk about no that's right
pre-production hour where it's like so
the reason this show works for those
that knows because of my morning show
during the morning show I read 8 000
articles then when we come upstairs an
hour before this show I'm like you
here's the news everybody like here's
everything I saw today what do you guys
think and then we pick what we think is
the big story
yeah all right this stupid b says I'm
glad to see such a great two-way
Advocate on the show love your content
Lucas I also hope Mr Potato Man Loves My
Name coming from a fellow Potato Man
oh yeah potato man's not here he left he
couldn't handle the heat he's weak and
he left and I'm just kidding I don't
know where he is Marshall P says Tim
whatever happened to timcast Grants to
help new projects projects fight the
culture war in the works
um the difficult thing is being one
person and doing all of this crazy stuff
it is very difficult however
um
I have given uh how many grants have I
given I think I've given two in the past
couple of weeks
so the issue is I don't know if I should
be announcing who I gave money to
you don't want them get targeted or
something I just you know yeah I don't
know there have been uh what's what's
the thing so the idea is once a month to
get Grant 10K to someone who's working
on a cultural project
to uh like I mean is it public is the
thing they're working on going to be a
public thing that everyone yes and so
this month I've given some money out but
I don't know if like they've given me
permission to just be like
they're funded by because you don't want
to Oprah bump them you don't want to be
like oh I don't care and they're not
ready for that kind of attention
right you know I don't want to yeah I
think because the two things that I just
recently funded I just chose to do I
didn't have a pre pre like I didn't go
to them and say hey here's the plan I
just gave them the money so it's like 20
grand I've given out in the past week so
the problem with not ever saying where
it's going no this is just one time
right now I'm saying in the future the
idea is like we'll hit someone be like
hey we want to shout you out on the show
and we want to give you some money for
this but these uh these these two uh
one's not really a it's not fair to say
I gave out 20. I gave I gave 10 grand to
a person doing very important work and
then I gave money to someone who's doing
some other fighting that's not super
cultural or whatever
but uh it's not necessarily where we're
trying to go with it so I don't think I
want to shout out if it's not a
consistent thing then but the idea is
like once a month maybe at the end of
the month we will say this is the person
we've chosen so the issue is it's going
to be in the Discord where we're trying
there's a lot of challenges to this if
it's in the Discord meaning you have to
be a member now all of a sudden there's
some kind of like sweepstakes thing to
it so then do we have to invest in the
project makes it very very difficult
so we're trying to figure out and the
idea was if you're in the Discord we
have people basically vote on it members
of timcast.com can be like hey we think
this project should be shouted out on
the show and we want to do that every
Friday we were going to shout out salty
draws one of our members last Friday but
he asked us to wait until he was ready
and we could actually review the book so
then we waited but that's the other
thing we're planning on doing Fridays we
will do a sponsor spot for our members
so people who are members at timcast.com
are sponsoring the show so it's like why
read out some corporate ad when we can
just shout you guys out and help your
project so that was a brilliant idea
coming from one of our members
so uh yeah Tim Kess grants is uh is is
preliminary and uh I might just give a
bunch of money away like crazy I don't
know it's awesome well like my thing is
I don't I don't need to buy another car
I I actually have a lot of cars uh I
don't and we do need more people okay if
the left has all this funding which they
do a lot I don't think anyone's going to
dispute that you know the right needs
funding too so when people can help do
some of that
it's pretty awesome maybe we can do like
a Mr Beast style thing
you know like giving money to people in
fun ways to make more money and then
give more money away but uh yeah the
general idea is to give money to people
so they can produce cultural work so
that if we give a hundred people money
and one of them writes you know a
masterpiece right then we're expanding
our cultural influence that's good so I
did just give out a bunch of money to
someone I thought deserved it I'm not
going to shout them out unless they
explicitly tell me they're cool with me
doing it so I'm not going to but there's
someone that everyone knows who's doing
very important work so what's happening
but yeah yeah so the issue is for for us
it's are we investing are we legally
cleared to do it and it's just it's it's
a nightmare getting all the stuff going
like we've been we got the coffee shop
in the works the coffee just started
shipping so there's a lot of bags of
cash this oh we're going to a cashless
society never mind yeah that's the thing
too like I think our coffee shop might
be like cash only or something
but I don't know how long you can resist
you know what I mean
right and are you potentially losing
business because some people who don't
carry around that much yeah too bad
remember this
the point is they're gonna they're gonna
demand taxes be paid in the currency
that's how the currency is going to
happen you have guaranteed value there
will be a banking crisis they will say
you have to uh can you have to convert
your cash to crypto to Fed coin or
whatever yep and then they're going to
demand that payment for taxes anyway
let's move on let's move on let's uh
read some more Super chats
Aaron says Serge thanks for crash
proofing the UFO
what is that uh I don't know what you're
talking about and you also spelled my
name incorrectly wow ignore that it's
all good though is this the fact that I
somehow managed to dislodge the UFO
every time I sit in this chair
maybe I don't know I'm not gonna say I
don't think I've done it at least three
times to be honest hey well when you're
making these pretty uh origami swans by
the way I would be making the entire
time I can understand you guys go do you
guys ever read the thing about the
Thousand Paper Cranes yes I did I just
wanted to have a Wish by the end of the
night oh true but then am I am I gonna
die from cancer what is this poor thing
why is its back so big look I don't have
origami paper I'm using Post-it notes
we're doing the best we can those should
work let me see
is it because they're not it's not like
jumpers can you like push on it is there
squares no like little frog here yeah I
can make those yeah the frogs you just
want some Post-it notes you want to join
in my the sticky part of it makes it
harder yeah origami gun see if I can
make a gun I can make a I can make a
balloon before you actually blow it up
and then you can write like a little
message on the inside of those and like
look through them can you make the
fortune teller thing yeah I can make
those it'll be hard with the sticky I'll
come better prepared for next show cool
appreciate it Jack Tatro says Lucas huge
fan of your work been looking forward to
this episode for the longest time I have
a few of your holsters and a hat signed
by your amazing staff training school
i-y-s-y-s what is that what does that
mean if you suck you suck oh yes that's
that's true yep yep
just some words to live by you know
that's right
Matthew Schneider says hey Tim I saw the
results of your Twitter poll earlier on
whether the mentally ill should vote
what are your thoughts makes me kind of
sad because I have a diagnosis but I'm
also stable and far from an insane
leftist so I was really really really
annoyed
at the responses that I got to that poll
I said should people with mental
illnesses be allowed to vote I did not
say
should the government be able to
subjectively Define mental illnesses so
they can restrict their political
enemies from voting and that's what so
many people started saying mental ill
people should be allowed to vote because
the government will claim their any
everyone's mentally ill I'm like that's
not the question the question is in your
mind
so like there were no external
parameters to this quite literally a
person is standing there and they're
like yes mentally ill should they vote
or should they not vote it's not a
question about the government but the
government can and will not do it's
whether or not you think people with
mental instances should be allowed to
vote that's it no context uh I I think
it's not my my response is you can't
really answer it in a poll which is
unfair that I asked it in a poll sure
because the the the answer is mentally
ill people within a certain confine of
men like a certain category of mentally
ill shouldn't vote
but uh how we Define mental illness can
vary in which someone has a mental
illness that doesn't impair their
judgment on policy issues it just makes
them like anxious and we call that a
mental illness or something you know
what I mean or uh do they consider it
ADHD mental illness probably I think I
think those are mentalism
Spectrum I just think that if you'll if
you if you took away if anybody was
mentally ill wasn't allowed to vote
as as much as I'm not saying I'm in
favor of that process I do think society
would be functioning to a much much much
much much better degree but my question
would be so a question that's always
thrown out about you know everyone
should have guns over shifts right down
guns people go what about someone with
Down syndrome and I'm like okay do you
actually know anyone with Down Syndrome
that really wants to own a gun and so I
kind of bring up the same question if
someone is actually mentally like
genetically their their brains whatever
got some issue like is this even a
question is this even a thing or is it a
a thing that a scenario were coming up
in our mind that's not actually a
legitimate scenario it's like the
nuclear weapons question when it comes
right to a exactly and people that are
like oh you know if you if you're a
Second Amendment absolutist do you think
people should be allowed to own nuclear
weapons well can people own nuclear
weapons no you need a uh that's wrong
State infrastructure to be able to
produce the government with them either
there was a guy who made a radioactive
death ray in his garage that's different
than he collect the nuclear weapon
you're talking about an explosive well
okay so when I say nuclear weapon my my
thought process goes to a nuclear a
thermonuclear weapon not something that
has a radiological component
who makes nuclear weapons usually states
make them they don't they're well there
may okay so they're probably made by uh
corporations
the weapons for them yeah so that was
the big issue when I said that
individuals have a right to keep and
bear nuclear weapons and everyone's like
no they don't I'm like it's private
corporations that are operating the
weapons for the government it's not you
know so so they have contracts in the
government it yes but no individual owns
the corporations those are all they're
all government government or they're
they're large the point is the
infrastructure required to produce or
procure or or to sustain a nuclear
weapon means that you can't Elon could
do it yeah maybe he's already launching
rockets and stuff at night but again
this this comes to the point where
you're talking about a handful of people
and States so practically nuclear
weapons as a as a means of self-defense
or is not an actual it's not an actual
top and that's and that's where I feel
like a lot of these arguments on like oh
can mentally yeah people are people
downstairs I'm like let's let's go find
some facts that this is actually
happening that it's an actual realistic
scenario of realistic what if and let's
not base a bunch of laws on a thing that
doesn't even happen yeah yeah I am and
restrict everyone else I would wonder
too if the pushback against like if you
said mentally ill people can't vote like
if they people would say well you'll
just you're discouraging people from
seeking counseling and potentially being
diagnosed because they think you'll take
this away from them and therefore that's
more dangerous I mean I don't think
anyone should vote but that's just me
so how do you uh Lucas look shocked I
don't know but I mean sure yeah
I'm an implant Phil I I don't have to
have an answer to say that to say that
no solution I don't want something to
happen I mean I don't you know I I I'm
I'm I've got that that whole like you
know emotional Anarchist thing going on
with me you know yeah there's always a
hierarchy system I understand that I
understand I understand that I
understand the world no one votes
exactly that that's what I've really
liked because again like as soon as you
when you whenever you have any kind of
you know government or whatever like
that there there are hierarchies and
stuff like that in corruption and stuff
like that and so if I'm gonna have my
own dream world it's going to be the uh
but in your dream world there's another
hierarchy form anyway like hierarchy's
form no matter what that's just part of
nature oh this is a nice one I don't
know this technique it's an alternative
uh cream yeah your cranes are fat I
don't understand how you're making them
I feed them too much they go to
McDonald's all the time mine are thinner
I don't know how you made this one it
feels like it'll stand when
yeah you can stand them up and then
there's another way to make it so you
can flap by pulling its tail but this
one doesn't
do some more research I've been making
cranes the same way since my our teacher
had us do it for hours and hours in like
the third grade I've never seen such an
effective art class he was like here's
this amazing story now if you make a
thousand of these and that's all we did
so why can't classes be like that now so
you may you you may not understand you
may not know this but um the reason why
I can make this paper crane is because
being part Korean and Japanese it is
just cellular memory and when I was a
child I could just do it but you'll also
notice it's pretty crappy and that's
because I'm only five percent Japanese
so it's only five percent effective in
my origami am I appropriating your
culture right now well yours suck
because you're white that's so true I'm
not even taking that as a racial insult
although I guess we're starting well I
think because of how wet you are too the
ginginess makes you like the extreme
white I think I think the rules of
wokeness are I'm allowed to say that
because you're appropriating my culture
but but to be fair someone told me this
is something I should be doing no let's
be real like there's probably some you
know middle-aged white dude who makes
the best origami ever and he like builds
castles and stuff like that all right
we'll read some more Super chats oh
where are we at T-Rex Pet Shop says
since Ian bailed I guess I'll have to
tell you guys that you forced my hand
and telling you the special deal we're
doing you'll get a free dog or cat toy
when you get 50 or more cat food dog
food or cat litter hey T-Rex Pet Shop
there you go yeah absolutely what are
the chances
here Daniel Smith says my Anheuser
delivery this week was two cases driver
said total deliveries this week was
around 200 pieces last week 100 then
Coors comes in with 30 cases and says
their deliveries have doubled oh wow oh
you'll love to see it oh I should have
bought the stock then oh put options put
options I wonder if bloodstock is going
to go down when the uh
when the sales data comes in because we
saw the first week a week later than
last week so like next week we're going
to get the sales data from the previous
week and I'm wondering it's going to be
like well I'm saying I should have
bought stock in the uh all the other
companies that were going to get more
business oh yeah no not them but no no
put options yeah you you you short their
stock so you've been oh yeah yeah I'm
not gonna buy any of that stock and I'm
not giving anybody Financial advice I'm
not talking to actually do anything
please don't please don't but but I
think I can tell people to do things
right yeah you're going to get the
they'll sue you oh man
what are you drinking drinking instead
like did anybody drink Bud Light and
have to like have a crisis I drink like
four times a year so I don't have to
worry about it that's great I need the
drink since 2018 or something like that
save so much money yeah search on this
one
no Bud Light for you not really I'm just
sad modelo's gone because I did like
Modelo my dad was good that's about it
William H says I've truly enjoyed
Steven's content over the years but I
just can't come back from what I heard
coming from his mouth directed at his
pregnant wife God speed Crowder I hope
you learn from this hopefully he
wouldn't have said it even if she wasn't
pregnant just
and so that was basically I was seeing a
bunch of comments from people and I'm
like all right I'll pull the story up
you know we'll talk about it but now you
can say you did you don't have to do it
tomorrow yeah I mean we probably will
because the story is going to get
crazier crowd is probably going to
address it I do think there is a merit
to talking about uh chaotic
relationships and being accountable for
the way you speak and address people I
think especially in like I I don't want
to stereotype too much for like
conservative male circles like it's not
a conversation that's easy to have but
it's important that people are aware of
their behavior and unfortunately I
didn't like I wouldn't want it to be
this venue but well and it would have
never come up if it had never been
public and so it wouldn't have been
talked about anyway so it's like it was
kind of made public and then
all right as we talked about Curtis
Terry says Phil big fan of your cover of
Thunder Rolls but was kind of
disappointed you didn't cover the third
verse any reason why the third verse is
not in the official release so we didn't
do that we do that live like if we do
like we'll do it acoustic we'll do uh
the third verse if we play alive but on
the record we decided to do the record
release that Garth actually did so
that's why will you cover uh Barbie girl
uh I know why not uh I feel like it'd be
fun to see I mean when you finish
watching Fast and the Furious
there is so much pressure to watch this
movie series I don't like it get on it I
gotta read this one uh David streaming
service David Violet says I usually only
donate two dollars but a guntuber gets
five dollars invite Lucas's dad Grantham
he's not my dad
but that's a good name that's a good
name yeah he stuck with it now yeah
forever when I got the M1A the first
thing they did was explained to me
and I was like oh yeah
and I like the fact that he's like he's
he's really funny too he's extremely
comical
is honestly more fun to hang out with in
person than on the internet I want to
meet him jack OPP says hey uh hates him
I'm a bartender in SD is that uh San
Diego or something South Dakota South
Dakota South Dakota well I work at a
bigger Casino I haven't moved Bud Light
in almost two weeks that's been an
interesting sight to see that's
definitely South Dakota you think yep
100 I find it it's fascinating because
there's there's a lot of uh casinos up
there because of uh reservations and
then uh but California's got a couple
don't they uh no I wouldn't imagine in
San Diego yeah yeah not San Diego I
think it's I think uh
yeah I don't know what casinos they have
I think it's South Dakota we've played
oh they have um what you call it when
you go out to Palm Springs or whatever
it is all the Springs does yeah Native
American one I've been there before
right casino that's Palm Springs not
it's not San Diego no I know yeah it's
far away
but I'm just saying like in California
they have it so I wonder if there's
anything down there
what have we with Spork which says gun
control is and has never been about guns
that has always been about control yes
no discussion there Ray Kane says gun
customization is the best part of video
games a street sweeper shotgun with 12
gauge 12 gauge fleshet fleshette is that
he said yeah it's fun uh have you played
um uh the division uh the first one long
time ago yeah I liked it and like all
the guns are real guns yeah they
actually use the names unlike other
companies we're like oh get sued yeah
yeah I thought it was fun you know you
and it shows you like a like a model of
the gun when you're in your inventory
that's the one where you're in in uh DC
right that's part two the first one well
that I think in part two they go back to
New York eventually okay but uh I
thought it was a great game it could
have been so much better but it was
pretty good yeah you're in New York the
pandemic wipes out the world yeah yeah
and then you're in Times Square and
stuff and it was really weird playing
the game with people who weren't from
New York having lived in New York and
playing it and it's like it's kind of
weird yeah was it modeled I'm assuming
they modeled it like one for one like
the actual story it wasn't one for I
mean yes but like still smaller yeah so
when you go to like uh 30 Rock it's a
smaller Plaza so they did they change
the spaces between each Landmark so you
can kind of get to them faster I think
so pick up a section of this I'm not
entirely sure it's it's a big map yeah
yeah it was it was huge yeah and then I
played part two and then that was in DC
and uh the weirdest thing I've ever
experienced was the first time I went to
DC I've been playing Fallout 3 for a
long time
and so I go to DC and I'm like oh I know
where everything is Chevy Chase what
yeah I go into the subway and I'm like I
know exactly where I am should I do it
over here yeah yeah and I'm like follow
me I know where I'm going and they're
like have you been here before like no I
just played Fallout three crazy
that's crazy man the future is going to
be weird you guys are wild man they
really aren't
let's grab some more Super chats
infernal Saxon says car Mufflers are
unregistered suppressors so why
okay it's a philosophical question we're
not going to talk about that Tiffany
Garrison says hey Tim I made you a
crochet Roberto Jr dressed like you and
I want to send him to you me and my
honey love the show do we still have the
P.O box up not on the website it's not
no
are you sure I didn't think it was but
then we're on pop culture crisis and Ian
said it was it's on yeah if you go if
you go to timcast.com contact us the P.O
box is there for sending things
we typically don't accept a lot of
things anymore because of security
issues but
that's how you do it so that'd be really
cool
um also I guess the rise with Roberto Jr
breakfast blend has been selling like
hotcakes nice and it's because Roberto
Jr is is it's his thing right so I think
what we're going to be launching is Mr
bocus's pumpkin spice experience
is the is the focus one and it's going
to be a year-round pumpkin spice
availability because we figured that
this fake seasonal pumpkin spice thing
we can do away with it's like you can
only get pumpkin spice in November and
you know get out of here Starbucks well
that didn't even make sense I remember I
went in and then I was like I want the
pumpkin spice cold room like we just got
rid of that I'm like why it's like
ginger and nutmeg come on dude hook it
up and then so we're gonna launch our
own Mr bocus's pumpkin spice experience
I wanted to be professor bocus
for so long I didn't realize he'd gotten
his tenure you know what I mean like or
Captain yeah Captain Boca I didn't
realize he was enlisted like you know we
need we need other steps in his life I
guess we'll do Mr bocus I think it's a
good idea to have a pumpkin pumpkin
spice honestly and it'll be available
year round yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
gonna have it stocked so I will tell you
there are challenges to this and we're
probably gonna have to hire someone to
basically Run cast Brew specifically
because right now we're just kind of
running on the side Allison takes care
of most of it but um maintaining stock
it's not like let me just tell you guys
and most people probably know this but
some of you may not realize we watch the
orders the product leaves the Shelf
there's actual it's it's not like they
make it we we have to make it per order
so it's you know so we will make a small
batch sell a bunch and then we have to
constantly have this this this flow of
ordering a bunch more not ordering too
much not making too much we want it's
going to be fresh for everybody when
they get it that means shipping times
will vary very you know so anyway it's
not like you're storing like blocks of
wood like that stuff exactly go bad yeah
so it's it's it's like right now we are
beginning to produce the next batch
because we have been selling like hot
cake so everybody smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member hang out in our Discord server
members only of course with like-minded
individuals and uh you can even call
into the show and submit questions and
that show will be live in about nine
minutes on the front page of timcast.com
you don't want to miss it you got to be
a member to watch it we're going to talk
about some not so family-friendly stuff
so again smash that like button you can
follow the show at timcastirl on
Instagram and Facebook you can follow me
personally at timcast everywhere Lucas
you want to shout anything out yeah
obviously the company I started uh T-Rex
dasharms.com is our website where you
can find training videos and products
and then I'm also on social media uh
Instagram Lucas strexarms Twitter which
I'm now only on Twitter because Elon
bought it right on so I'm on there right
on I am Phil Monte lead singer of All
That Remains the band is All That
Remains you can find us on Spotify all
of the Apple music the YouTubes and
stuff I am Phil that remains on Twitter
Philip remains official on Instagram and
Anna Claire I'm Hannah brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should go to
timcast.com skip everything else you
don't need it I'm just kidding click on
the read tab see the Articles from me
from Adrian Norman from Chris Bartman a
lot of good work coming up there if you
want oh and follow it at timcast news on
Twitter and Instagram if you want to
follow me you can follow me on Instagram
at handclare.beat and on Twitter at hcbr
mall thanks so much
and I am search.com I will keep uh
pestering Hannah Claire about watching
my favorite film franchise which is Fast
and Furious your favorite film Channel
yes it's great it's all about family you
know it's fantastic all right everybody
we're talking about we will see you all
over at timcast.com in a few minutes
thanks for hanging out cheers